oops this February meeting of the
council I'd like to take this
opportunity to say how lovely it is to
see councillor Wendy Turner back in the
committee Hall in the chamber so mayor
first all my chips and domestic
arrangements the toilets are situated
outside the meeting room opposite the
stairs cold water is also available in
the breakout area outside the meeting
room if the fire alarm should sound
please leave the meeting room by
following the fire exit signs and meet
on the Ipswich Town Football Club
training pitch do not re-enter the
building until you're told it was safe
to do so please switch off all mobile
phones and turn them to silent
I would like to mine ever impressive
that this meeting will be broadcast live
on the internet will be P capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except for there
are confidential or exempt items if you
make a representation to the meeting
you'll be deemed by the council to have
to consent it to being filmed by
entering this room you were also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for webcast
webcasting and/or training purposes the
council members of the public and press
may record film or photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
finally can members and officers please
ensure that you press the microphone for
speaking and turn it off when you're
finished can I move to the agenda please
so item number one apologies for absence
Thank You chair I have received
apologies from councillor Phillips thank
you item number two declarations of
interest by councillors in accordance
with delegated authority the monitoring
officer has granted dispensations to all
members in respect to the 2221 budget
papers do we have any other declarations
has debris step madam chair yes I
declare a non-pecuniary interest on the
gateway 14 I'd and
the chair of the holding company cancer
stringer yeah just thought I'd being
citizen a bit Suffolk technically with a
loan of last resort for the tsypko so I
need to declare that interest
but in the same regard cider would do
something o'clock okay great chess
please cancel avoid head
so in in us in a non symbol away I need
to declare an opportunity interest local
interest as the director of gateway 14 I
don't want to declare an interest but
I'm sorry that I cannot hear I didn't
hear either councillor Bruce - all
counselor Whitehead because they would
not facing the mic when they spoke so
can I just remind people who you speak
to the mic not to the chair cancel a gig
did you yes thank you - no I'm also a
citizen of bits of it so I'd like to
declare an interest as well thank you so
moving on item number three MC / 19 / 35
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on 23rd of January 2020 for
accuracy only are there any issues with
accuracy councillor Mansell that's why
I'm just trying to find the bit I think
it's on page 17 it's a bit awkward when
I don't have bits of paper to find the
right thing is it page 17
page 17 I asked a question about the
proportion of people take that with the
proportion of claimants and there was an
aunt and I did reiterate it was the
proportion that I was talking about not
the number but in the minutes it only
refers to the number of claimants not a
proportion they will get that seen to
thank you very much
could I have a purpose or a councillor
Madison thank you
yeah I I'm I could be mistaken but at
the top of page 15 we've we find an
answer to council the Mellon's question
about gateway 14 energy etc I've got a
feeling that was probably councillor
Fleming that I said that question I
could be wrong maybe that's 10 pounds
for a home star I think I could add a
proposal for the minutes please Thank
You Collette mayor have a seconder
thank you cancer sick a little chilly
all those in Fraser thank you gets
passed item number four Chairman's
announcements I refer you to pay for MC
19 slash 36 to be noted calorie burn
thank you very much chair at this point
I'd like to take the opportunity to
thank counselor John Matheson for
organizing the Zed port meeting that was
held here on the 7th of February where
there was standing room only in the
Elizabeth room looking at sustainable
housing so I'd like to put that thanks
on that the record thank you thank you
alright so number five leaders
announcements I would like to invite
councillor Morley to present her update
[Music]
Thank You chair
equality and diversity I did mention
this last month
please Claridge all members have not
already done so to attend the mandatory
equality and diversity training
so far we've run eight separate sessions
these have run both during the day and
the early evening and there are still
nine mid Suffolk councillors who have
not attended please rectify the
situation
neither market station I'm delighted to
inform you the application for funding
for the Needham access project has been
awarded 380,000 pounds from the
Department for Transport this was
announced yesterday and while this
doesn't automatically mean the project
is ready for delivery we do need to do
further feasibility and continual on the
sill funding process it is a huge step
forward and demonstrates that the strong
partnerships we have in place with
Greater Anglia and others are working
I'm delighted that following the
council's commitment to work towards the
Unison end violence at work charter we
have now received confirmation that
we've met the standard required for each
of the ten criteria as a consequence we
can now become signatories to the
Charter unison is holding its national
community conference next week
and we'll announce our achievement along
with other employees have also gained
this charter status achieving this chart
is an important validation of the
commitment commitment the council has to
its staff and the effort it makes to
ensure that they are protected from the
risk of violence or aggression whilst
they go about their work I would like to
thank the team that carried out this
work and I'm advised that the admission
was noted as very high standard by
unison
the next meeting of the Suffolk public
sector leaders is tomorrow all
councilors are of course welcome to
attend the meeting which starts at 10:30
at East Suffolk House in Melton there
are three items on the agenda that I
want to mention tonight and these are we
are anticipating that funding will be
approved for the second year of support
for 50,000 pounds to address needs
that's young people not in education
employment or training which we deliver
through the mix in stone market we are
putting forward proposals for how we
will spend two hundred and fifty
thousand pounds of poured business rates
to help develop the innovation cluster
on gateway 14 and a proposal to create a
new two-year Suffolk housing coordinator
post who will be employed by mid Suffolk
on Bebo on behalf of the wider Suffolk
system I'm happy to share the paper and
PowerPoint presentation sitting out the
details with councillors if it is
supported by Suffolk public sector
leaders tomorrow planning offices for
Baber
and mid Suffolk District Council's are
in the running for a national award
having paved the way for technological
advances as part of the 21st century
planning the development management team
which looks after planning matters for
both councils is shortlisted in the best
use of digital and Technology category
at the annual I easy public sector
transformation Awards 2020 this category
recognizes the innovation use of digital
tools and technology in order to improve
services for residents judges were
impressed by how the team had
streamlined the planning application
process for residents across the
districts bringing teams and systems
together in order to become one of the
top performing of authorities for timely
planning decisions the team has also
introduced electronic case management
and a mobile app in order to put vital
information at the fingertips of
officers and the public with public
searches of information leaving
from 600,000 in 27 to 23 600,000 in 2017
to 1.3 million in 2018 and although not
it yet in use they have started to pave
the way for future technological
advances such as the use of drones and
augmented reality as part of the 21st
century planning process the team must
now wait until the award ceremony in
London on Wednesday next Wednesday to
find out if they have managed to fend
off stiff competition from the
categories other shortlisted finalists
which are come Cumbria County Council
and East Ayrshire council and the
ceremony will be live streamed from 6
o'clock for anyone wishing to follow
online Thank You Chancellor Carter yes
good the chair please reassure me that
we would not have any further
last-minute changes to any agenda
sorbets to perform at or for meetings
such changes do have a rather decimation
effects go by oh how I can proceed as my
nerves to implement any four measures
began to answer questions were speaking
so canopic make sure that there's no
last-minute changes to any meetings
please okay
Thank You chair and members may be aware
that um Manor Farm doctors surgery in
baton in my ward has been closed this
week for deep cleaning after a patient
reported a suspected case of drive and a
novel coronavirus can the leader
reassure me that since an outbreak of
this virus whether it comes sooner or
later is going to have significant
impact on the work of the council and
can she reassure me that the
administration has plans in place so
that services continue to be provided to
the public thank you
yes I can and if you're concerned we can
arrange a further briefing are there any
other questions of councillor Morley so
I will move on to to item number six to
receive notifications of petitions in
accordance with council procedure rules
none receive chair item number seven
questions by the public in accordance
with council procedure rules no receive
chair item number eight questions by
councillors in accordance with council
procedure rules I refer you to the
questions by councillors in the table
papers so question number one is the
councillor you burn - councillor Morley
thank you very much chair the cost of
member allowances and expenses has
increased from two hundred and sixty
nine thousand three hundred and ninety
three pounds and thirteen pence in 2017
18 - four hundred forty two thousand
five hundred and sixty three hundred and
thirty nine pence which is a difference
of a hundred and seventy three thousand
one hundred seventy pounds and twenty
six pence please could you provide the
explanation for this increase
there was a one-off increase in the
member allowances in 1819 due to the
back payment of the basic allowance and
special responsibility allowances that
was made following a review of the
members remuneration scheme carried out
by the independent remuneration panel
this panel was tasked with looking at
members allowances and to take into
account the changes to members roles
following the creation of the leader
cabinet model which was constituted in
May 2017 the new scheme was about
adopted by full Council in June 2018 the
figures forecast for 1920 showed the
projected decrease in the amount of
members allowances which will be a more
accurate reflection of the cost
following a reduction in the number of
members since the elections in May 2019
as we when do you have a supplementary
question thank you very much chair on I
do the diff that the difference is that
I thank the leader for your answer to
the question the difference is you refer
to you wouldn't be wouldn't make up that
total difference of a hundred seventy
three thousand pounds because some of
the backdating is only it would be up
between about forty and sixty thousand
so I would really like to see the exact
figures please to explain the
differences otherwise we're not going to
be able to make a good a true comparison
year-on-year so if I could be provided
with the exact figures I'd appreciate it
thank you very much chair I'm happy to
ask Katherine still to send out that
briefing of you on question number two
councillor deep to councillor Brewster
Thank You chair we recently heard from
the cabinet member from it three
economic growths at part of our ongoing
work on project delivery for
regeneration and capital projects part
we'll take account of climate change as
stronger economic growth tends to be
closely linked to a higher carbon
footprint and as we're now in a climate
crisis could we be told which parts of
the council's work on regeneration and
capital projects will not
account of climate change thank of your
question yes as part of your refreshed
project management framework across both
councils all project initiation
documents have a section on the
environment project managers when
commencing a project and throughout the
life of that project are required to
complete an environmental impact
assessment which considers positive and
negative environmental impacts of each
scheme as new projects come to the
various program boards environmental
impact is considered as part of the
overall deliverability this means every
regeneration and capital project will
take account of climate change and
ensure any impacts are assessed and
properly mitigated past week you have a
supplementary question yes so do you
think you check I would like to ask if
if the cabinet member could please look
at the work of other councils as well
with the future future proofing every
single aspect of our work to give just
two examples very short ones Oxford City
Council has allocated a climate
emergency budget of 18 million pounds
for capital investment and a million
pounds operational budget to ensure
delivery and Warwick District Council
today announced they will hold a
referendum on increasing council tax to
provide the necessary funds so there are
good examples out there yes I'm sure we
can take account of other councils and
it has to be remembered at this time
that our economy budget is actually the
smallest budget on this council or one
of the smallest is I think there's two
there's another one the same level and
but I'm sure that our cabinet members or
economy and sorry our ad for economy and
is probably aware over those facts and
you know I will have a thank you um
question number three counselor Willem -
counselor flapman Thank You chair
the council is making a grant to mid
Suffolk Citizens Advice about six
thousand seven hundred pounds per annum
for each of the next three years could
we please be assured that there are no
specific conditions attached to the
making of the ground Thank You
councillor Ellen for your question the
grant of this nature will clearly have
reasonable conditions attached that the
applicant uses the money for the purpose
set out in the application for example
and that they deliver the proposed
outputs I can reassure you that these
conditions will be agreed with mid
Suffolk Citizens Advice prior to issuing
the offer letter rather than simply
being imposed upon them without any
dialogue councillor Willems do you have
a supplementary question Thank You Jerry
yeah I'm pleased to hear that can I
therefore assume that the conditions
will be the normal miss up at district
council conditions in when they make
grants and can you confirm that you will
not require Miss Suffolk citizens advice
to seek to reorganize or closed branches
this moment in time I don't think
there's any of those going to take place
counselor well and if anything changes I
will let you know question number four
counselor welcome to counselor Morley
the spring didn't work very well did it
the corporate outputs document was
discussed at a joint overview scrutiny
committee meeting held on 8th of January
2020 a number of the outputs are stated
as giving support to various initiatives
could we have clarity around the type of
support to be given particularly whether
it is financial support or support by
offices and or members of the two
councils and what outcomes arias are
expected in respect of each of these
initiatives Thank You councillor Willem
as was explained during the over
overview and scrutiny committee meeting
there are approximately nine mid Suffolk
references to providing support in the
corporate outputs these reflect the fact
that the council has an impact not just
in terms of what it directly delivers
but also by working in partnership with
others where the partner is the lead the
reference to support therefore relates
to political and officer support but
does not exclude financial support where
any proposal for direct financial
support is made however this will come
forward through cabinet for decisions
I think the intended outcomes for each
of these is obvious from the document
for example the Museum of East Anglian
life to become the National Museum of
food for business businesses to access
our local shop front and accessibility
funding etc but I'm happy to provide
further details outside of this meeting
for anywhere where councillor Elam has
additional queries um have you got a
supplementary question yes thank you
chair thank you for your response I'm
unclear about
reason for supporting the a14 expressway
since to add capacity to a major trunk
road will increase traffic and are
equally unclear how increasing traffic
fits with our declaration of a climate
emergency could you explain please
I think that this is rather a long
answer so we'll provide a response
outside of this meeting but it is
imperative that our infrastructure is
able to deliver our leads moving on to
question number five is councilor when
I'm again to councilor morally promise
this is the last time Springs worn out
at a joint overview scrutiny committee
meeting held on the 8th of January the
leader of our councils lady that various
task groups would be providing the
timescales for achieving the outcomes to
be achieved in 2020 21 and beyond our
task groups actively working towards
providing agreed program dates to be
included in the document before the
start of the municipal year 2020 2021
thank you thank you Kelso I believe that
the chief executive addressed a similar
question to this at the cabinet meeting
that adopted these corporate outputs as
he explained this is intended to be the
first and last time that the corporate
outputs are presented to councillors in
this way this is a reflection of the
fact that the outputs were developed in
parallel with the corporate plan now
that the corporate plan and these
outputs have been adopted they're being
incorporated into action plans for each
of our six strategic priorities these
action plans are a combination of work
that is already underway and new actions
performance will then be measured from
quarter 1 of 20 2021 against these
action plans with this in mind
officers are my request and
in a review of our performance framework
counselor morally I'm counseling LM
sorry do you have a supplementary
question I do I'm going to be short this
time chair yeah I'm pleased that
performance will be measured from
quarter one of twenty Twenty twenty one
against these action plans but we need
to know what we're measuring again so
will we have the action plans with dates
against them before the start of the
municipal year so that we can start to
measure performance against those days I
think that's what I said the some of
them may not have dates because the
climate changed to a sport and not
finalizing there until after that but as
soon as we know those dates we'll let
you know I'm a question number six
councillor Mansell - councillor burn and
thinking - of our adopted neighborhood
plans have recently been put to the test
at flying Affairs Committee
recommendations from development control
officers were to go against the
neighbourhood plan policies because they
felt that they were lacking in housing
allocations and or policy wording given
that MSD C is obliged to support
communities making neighborhood plans
how are we ensuring that they are
getting the best impartial advice thank
you for your question councilman
this matter is clearly topical and has
been the subject of much discussion that
not just planning referrals but also the
recent training exercise for councillors
the officer recommendations contain
significantly more neurons than you have
suggested within your question and I
think it is important that we continue
to talk about weight to be applied
rather than your more adversary
language of going against on that at
that aside I do recognize the sentiment
our officers are serious in their intent
to support communities to develop
neighborhood plans though they provide
technical advice on the processes
involved and signpost to impartial
sources such as locality to ensure
communities into the process with their
eyes open and optimize the support
available to them officers also advise
on funding sources available and help
groups to engage their own professional
advice as well as providing both
informal feedback as plans progress and
formal feedback during the relevant
consultation stage there is a wealth of
information available on our website
which further explains the support
available however because of the
importance of this subject I've provided
a more detailed and substantive response
in writing but I do not intend to read
that to you during this meeting I am of
course course happy to discuss the
matter further with you and officers
outside of the meeting if that would
assist chancinite sir do you have a
supplementary question thank you yes I
must admit your written response huh it
was a bit too lengthy for me to take in
in the five minutes I received it before
the meeting and I think there may be
more questions that arise from it but I
do have one question which you do
pertain to in your last paragraph of the
written response that I've got and I
thank you for your verbal response
because it sounded a lot more
interesting than the written one as our
JLP progresses to examination and
adoption well we need to appoint more
staff to provide support to the
communities who will need to review
their neighbourhood plans in light of
our joint Local Plan and of course there
may be a number of new commodities that
realized the benefits of having a
neighbourhood plan so that was my
follow-up question and I'm sure I will
have some others that I would perhaps
ask
outside meeting yes thank you
Reverend question but well I think it's
a little too far away for me to answer
immediately I that's that that will
certainly be borne in mind as the
progression of the neighborhood plant
develops sorry the local town develops
and as and when resources if they are
required we will we will consider supply
so moving on to agenda item number nine
MC / 19 / 37 overview and scrutiny
committee reports I would like to take
councillor Williams report in two parts
the first part will cover everything but
the gateway 14 element this element of
his report will be taken in part 2 of
the agenda and the council actually
discussed the gateway 14 reports
councillor Whalum please introduce your
report it's just been noting thank you
chair
yeah the report covers five topics a
corporate plan outputs the Western
Suffolk Community Safety Partnership
gateway 14 draft general fund budget
draft housing revenue account budget
there were four separate meetings held
during January the gateway 14 discussion
was held with the public excluded but
this particular report has been written
specifically for a public agenda so I'm
happy to take questions on any of these
topics but obviously discussion on the
recommendations from the gateway 14 item
will more logically be taken at item 17
a does anyone have any questions for
councillor Ellen
councillor Passmore thank you very much
chairman and chief I just wanted to ask
and regarding the Community Safety
Partnership meeting do you think we as a
council actually make enough use of the
various items that are discuss looking
at various grants opportunities I know
there's quite a range of activities that
the
said the partnership deal was with but
it's very difficult within that huge
partnership covering about two-thirds of
the land area of Suffolk for our voice
to be heard how effective do you think
that might be or if you've got any
suggestions from the committee or how it
might be improved so that we can there
play a more active role in that Thanks I
think our offices and our members are
very active within that partnership and
clearly they work with Kim warned of of
sublet police and I don't think any of
any of the people within that
partnership would be back with it coming
forward if there was more that we could
do but it's certainly we have a we have
Sarah Munsell is a council man so he's a
member of the partnership and I'm sure
that if there were more that we could do
she would she becoming a saying so thank
you is there any other questions for
councillor Ellen okay thank you very
much councillor Wellum moving on to
agenda item number 10 and MC / 1938
general front General Frank budget 2022
2021 and four-year outlook I refer you
to the revised appendix see in the
tables papers I would like to invite
councillor Whitehead to introduce this
paper and Ruth the recommendations in
the report could I have a seconder I was
thinking John would you like to make
your proposal thank you madam chairman
I'm pleased to present to members this
evening report MC 1938 this is a fourth
general further budget which I presented
to Council when they introduced my first
budget in 2017
I told full council it was gratifying to
inherit such a robust financial position
for our general fund and such strong
reserves and at that time I put forward
three main factors behind this firstly
the Magnificent contribution of our
previous
Akala Halley in his past to worship with
his portfolio secondly the uninterrupted
period of strong economic discipline and
strict financial prudence exercised by
conservative administrations over many
years and thirdly the significant
contributor of our management team in
consistently delivering positive annual
financial out turns against budget and
their exercise of street financial
discipline I felt a great burden of
responsibility in preserving councilor
Haley's legacy I'm also pleased to say
that the second and third mentioned
factors continue to this day now prior
to the budget coming today before from
council it has been considered by
cabinet in January and February meetings
we have source had been before the
overview and scrutiny committee the
budget has also been searched above a
detailed presentation by our finance
team to an all member briefing in
January but I do remain conscious that
we have 12 new members who joined the
council last May and for many this may
be their first real exposure to local
authority finances so I do want to
reinforce and peel evasions
even if some of this is old news to
longer serving members we've had a
deliberate policy of minimizing the use
of new homes bonus in balancing our
budgets over the last few years and
indeed none of our actual out turns
since new homes burn has started have
taken a penny from new homes bonus for
our normal council winner house this
2021 budget likewise uses no new homes
bonus to balance the books
within the report paragraph 810 I think
clearly shows wise is important because
new homes bonus will fall away to zero
by 2020 324 now something surely will
replace it but who knows what or indeed
how much of this stage we do know that
district council funding is not the
government's top priority going forward
central government's for gramps have
fallen away over the last few years and
that's why we've been determined as a
council that we can stand on our own two
feet
generating our own income
supporting our expenditure we do this we
achieve this by for principal methods
one we have made various pool
investments all of which produce income
streams - we are building up Cisco 250
million pounds by investing in secured
real estate assets with quality tenants
paying a significant rental income
stream and 3 we grow our tax base that's
new housing along with bringing empty
properties back into use and that
provides a 1% + increase to our tax base
each year and finally for over the years
we've made modest below inflation
increases to our council tax this year
we're proposing a 1.6 6% increase which
works out at 2 pound 76 pence per year
for a bandy home now that's just 28
pence a month extra for a typical person
paying Direct Debit in 10 monthly
instalments and do note that 60% of our
homes actually fall into bandhas A to C
so they were actually pay even less in
this modest increase and incidentally
it's also the lowest increase for any
District Council in Suffolk this budget
shows a healthy surplus even after
setting aside to quite large stones and
money 1 for 1 million pounds and one for
half a million pounds
1 million pound is to commercial
development risk management reserve
because our in district developments of
brownfield and green field sites such as
a middle school the needle mark
headquarter site and it's particularly
our gateway 14 site these are not risk
free development nether is so it's best
to have this extra contingency a half
million pound is for climate change
initiatives some interesting ideas
emerge from several meetings with the
opposition groups and some of these have
been passed across the climate change
task and finish group for scoping and
several of our office is also putting
for several work examining and refining
these proposal now that work is ongoing
but it's closed or clear to me
to take real action on climate change
then real money will need to be set
aside this half a million pound is just
a starter for 2020 21 man though it has
been welcomed by the cross party
overview scrutiny committee we are
spending from our earmarked reserves
join next year but reserves will still
be above 10 million pounds by the end of
2020 1 F shown in paragraph 7.6 the
figure I'm quoting ignores community
infrastructure levy as I regard that a
special and ring-fenced it is great to
still have such a healthy financial
cushion as we go forward it will let us
invest in our leisure services business
development and the many emerging
environmental initiatives the report
front you also covers capital all
detailed in Appendix B fourteen point
nine million spend in 2021 which will
include the balance of Cisco a Needham
mark
Needham Market Lakes Visitor Center cafe
and Leisure Centre development along
with a significant spent significant
carry-forward spend from prior year just
ending remember should also note our
proposed change to reduce the 25 cent
discount for unoccupied and unfurnished
residential development the dwellings in
three months down to 28 days that brings
in more council tax it acts as an
incentive not to keep properties vacant
we still gives landlords time to reload
that property the following concerns
raised by various members sorry John
you're just over your time can you can
you round mind this up thank most refer
to section 12 pay policy and if you can
just give me an with before moving
recommendations I do want to acknowledge
the hard work that the finest teams put
into this budget preparation so along
with the three detail reports here
they've had similar deadlines to produce
similar the baver
continuing to work on the current year
numbers and also due to lengthy delays
by our external auditors means our team
are still assisting the auditors were
last year's conclusions so our finest
team were dribbling an amazing number of
balls in the air so I
salute their professionalism their
dedication back office staff really get
the my rounding serve so look just want
to say a big thank you to them so happy
toaster questions and the falestine
we're here to assist me but first like
to move the full suite of
recommendations thank you
could I have a seconder Thank You chair
I'm happy to second we will now move to
questions and debate councillors may ask
as many questions as they wish however
they must be relevant to the subject
under discussion and must be a question
when we get to the debate element
councillors will only be allowed to
speak once for three minutes and this
will be timed
it's a council early burn thank you very
much chair I'd like to move an amendment
to the draft budget today if I may um
together we the green group and the Lib
Dem group have worked to bring forward
proposals for mid Suffolk's budget as
half the council and therefore
representing half the residents of mid
Suffolk we have coordinated to produce
visionary ambitious and financially
sound proposals for the next financial
year we started work back in November
holding meetings with finance officers
senior officers and the administration
to ensure that we can deliver proposals
that both respond to the climate
emergency we face and future-proof mid
suffer for all our residents visitors
and businesses we produce ten key
proposals and following work with
officers and members some aspects of
these are now being taken forward and
have already been included in the
corporate outputs for next year these
proposals include promoting sustainable
new homes through the provision of
technical and planning advice improving
tree cover across the district providing
greater access for to the council
improving the Democratic relationship
with residents especially young people
and improving residents and businesses
confidence in and experience of planning
we commend the administration for taking
this on and agreeing to this
it has been recognized that this is a
clear example of how our ideas are
providing meaningful action for our
communities however it is not enough and
we can do much more to future-proof
our district which is what this
amendment proposes to do you have the
amendment in front of you on page 25 of
the tabled papers and this has been
since checked by finance and legal as
well as been the subject of intense
discussions with the chief executive the
leader and other members and officers we
are pleased there has been so much
positive interest in these perhaps this
is an example of our continuing ideas
and vision that we are providing towards
the council and for the administration
however as members representing half the
council we're happy to provide good
ambitious plans of the future none of
this is new many councils are doing this
already such as ensuring all new council
homes are carbon neutral in New York and
leading by example encouraging
developers do the same such as with the
said pod examples we recently heard
about we should be encouraging good
environmentally efficient design and
ensuring that this is available to all
whether a self-build or small developer
many councils are investing in electric
vehicle charging points to promote
business in their town and city centres
why aren't we doing so and looking at
the examples of Peterborough and Dundee
for example combine this with supporting
residents to extend their stay in Stowe
market and ensuring the more elderly and
vulnerable can easily access the town we
encourage much more active use of our
districts main town and finally we need
to get back our community's confidence
and planning we've shown how our ideas
are already being taken forward but we
need to bolster our planning committee
work with further investment in highways
to prove we are listening and acting on
our community's concerns we have money
in the bank we should not be in the
business of stockpiling 9.2 million
pounds of taxpayers money which is just
10% less than our net budget a Paris
council with this level of reserves
would be sanctioned this is not our
money and at present we can't
confidently see how the administration
is going to spend what we have our ideas
in this amendment won't cost the earth
but we'll help to meet the challenge of
the climate emergency and future-proof
the district for our communities each
year we put forward well worked out
proposals mapping advising some vision
and ambition for the council learning
from what other councillors do and
investing in our communities
I urge you to accept this amendment and
ask my colleague John field to second it
Thank You chair if you have a seconder
thank you are you serving your right to
speak yes I wish the second this
amendment we do recognize that you've
discussed issues with us and made some
amendments to your budget notably
allocating some 500k to issues that
impact on drivers of climate change
however we believe that our ideas of
much wider than just the environmental
issues important as those particular
issues are and the amendment really
proposes to cover a number of our ideas
forward we propose action to ensure all
housing is close to zero carbon as
possible and that we accelerate our
housing program at a cost of increase
but realistic borrowing we should aim to
increase our housing stop substantially
over the next 30 years replacing the
stock of sold on right to buy or that
just unfit to upgrade to modern
standards we believe that both issues
are our own vital we desperately need
new housing at low rent to support our
low wage economy
unfortunately tourism leisure care and
the farming do not play well we need to
provide a clear lead on the achievements
of the possible in sustainable housing
we need to help local builders get valid
modern designs without high individual
startup expenditure solving all the
unfamiliar issues they have with a near
Passivhaus homes
competition that's proposed will produce
outstanding deliverable designs that are
well publicized on electric vehicles we
just need to get moving the tide is
turning
it will be good to be on the front foot
if we just enabled all the price taxi
owners to switch to the hybrid plug-in
version it would be a great start but
particularly on highways planning we
need to get the endless resistance to
housing growth we need attenuated
residents who just don't want their
environment to change to change whatever
and lead need whoever these houses the
position is amazed significantly worse
by the common belief that highways
solutions to support development they're
just not adequate one officer in the
county who can spend up to four hours on
each development can't do the planning
or negotiation necessary to satisfy
residents that they are interests are
being addressed if you look at the
increase within the district the local
asset value the gross domestic product
or even just the SIL the yield of a
value of reducing opera's efficient and
therefore d'lai far outweighs the cost
we would propose the value of the
enhancement that would be I believe
fantastic so please support this
amendment cancel Whitehead to accept
this amendment
this one I'd like to thank castlereagh
burden counselor field for bringing
forward this amendment because as many
cows as we where there's been detailed
political discussions through a series
of meetings prior to the budget
committee counsel captain these meetings
involved both myself counsel morally
counselor brewster counselor burn
counselor field counselor stringer and
counselor well my think of includes
everyone there and this these had been
to discuss a ten idea to propose by the
green Liberal Democrat groups I'm
accumulating the administration
specifically agreeing to adopt a number
of additional items to the corporate
outputs at the last cabinet meetings the
five budget amendments proposed tonight
were not adopt adopted as additional
corporate outputs but only because the
administration has already developed
very similar corporate outputs
themselves but it is fantastic to see
that we research alignment across all
our political dreams truth through the
conversations between councilors we've
already shared the detail scoping work
that offices are developed for each of
these five amendments what this scoping
shows is that while we already agree to
the principles sitting behind each these
five proposals further work is needed to
ensure we avoid duplication with work
already underway ensure that they are
deliverable and ensure that such
proposals will actually help deliver the
outcomes that we all want to see
so in summary I'm actually slightly
confused rated by this amendment because
as opposition groups will know if this
premature and necessary the furby
scoping work don't you just be saying
yes we know it's already at okay right
but budget is already in place we
service budgets additional five hundred
thousand and indeed from the nine
million pound reserves at Council even
if so keen to spend the administration
that cannot therefore support this
amendment tonight
so we were we were moved into a
question-and-answer period and so
remember these are questions counsel
Otten first very much
um yes these are questions for Rachel
poor John sorry it's the question of
John and yes I'd like to ask failed no
this is just on the amendment it is on
the amendment yes ever I say question
needs to be - Rachel no - John field
given that accounts of whiteheads given
such a detailed response it's only fair
that therefore the question these are
all centered and directed to him on the
amendment because he's provided such
detailed comments on this there seems
fair to me so I'm gonna say that's okay
and yeah I would just like to understand
why you feel you could not support the
item 5 in the amendment some other
members here may recall that only a few
days ago I actually asked that County
Council increased a number of highways
offices for this very reason and I would
just like to tell you that I had quite
significant support on that individual
item so I believe that there is some
real need as far as the public is
concerned dealing with major planning
applications that this should be given
much more serious consideration answer
that John
over the years I certainly had real
concerns on various highway issues that
have come in on planning applications in
my ward but I mustn't lose track of the
fact that Suffolk County Council are the
Highways Authority and they're the ones
that provide the highway related
responses on all planning applications
so whether we employ our own experts or
not the character castle will still be
required to comment and attend planning
meetings the planning process already
involves competing professional opinions
and separate Highway expertise sometimes
employed by the district council it just
feels that this would not add clarity or
confidence to the that the popos Lee is
actually trying to see counselor
stringer sorry cancer the way this
should be just a one-word answer do you
agree with the oxford english dictionary
definition of the word emergency that it
means a dangerous situation requiring
immediate action
I wouldn't word answer probably
counselor personal thank you very much
chill s the most pivotal answer I've
heard in the bet 53 years and just a
couple of points here I absolutely
understand a lot of these points are
they coming from
I haven't obviously been party to some
of the discussions have taken place
between between two groups but I do
wonder whether some of these things
couldn't be adopted anyway within the
our existing plans without having to
necessarily allocate extra resources
because I don't think there's some very
good ideas here the only word of caution
I would have is it perhaps could be
slightly more specific and we don't need
the base of it I know this is a point
let me just finish place a few made
chairman and we need to be precise about
exactly what we're asking for so for
example we can't debate
what's the stable means tonight because
we'll be here all night we'll have views
I think I know where that come from when
it comes to electrification are we sure
where we're going it's a good idea is it
going to be future proofed as we go
forward for these superfast charging
systems you can get now and with you I
don't know enough of that so what I'm
saying is a word of caution as it stands
I'm not sure I can quite support it as
it is but we don't want to lose some of
these ideas so my question is looking at
some of that can some of these beening
be incorporated any case without having
to allocate extra budgets and so on
anyway
counselor field I'm sorry counselor
Whitehead joint answers so what I just
feel that the reason I gave up a long
response to the amendment was to say
that so much this is actually in
progress
and being scoped and so simple answer is
yes this time thank you chair yes if I
if I could answer I think what one of
our concerns is for example electric
vehicle charging charging points so many
councils are putting these in how many
if we've gotten to day market
Vedant okay we've got one at Koster that
doesn't work at the moment in them on
the a14 so other councils are doing this
work and we are way behind so so let's
know that there's none of this waiting
for technology or just seeing what's
going to happen there's there's so many
things that other councils are doing
that we could just learn on from and
take off of the shelf so I'm surprised
that visit these things here aren't
being included because it's it's so
simple to actually put forward the
electric DVD charging points we've got
company and stow market that does them
how many officers had from mid Suffolk
or visits then in the last year none I
haven't seen anybody you know we could
be using them with our own with the
House bill in competition for example
we've found things like that before you
could actually get off the shelf designs
for people to use and though that could
be done tomorrow so all of this could be
done we'd have to wait for anybody other
councils are doing this but these things
aren't being taken afford at the moment
which is why we put them forward as an
amendment thank you - thank you Jeff yet
my question is is it's quite specific on
the on the fifth one of the amendments
and maybe the officers can help and that
is to ask how much we've actually spent
on external support to our planning
officers in relation to highways matters
I understand we've spent quite a
significant amount of money on one
particular application
I wondered whether offices have got any
kind of idea of how much we actually
spent on that particular room external
support through you I'm not aware of the
immediate figures I mean we have a close
working relationship now now that we're
in the other house and from our point of
view as officers we think that's as
effective as it has ever been at this
council and to my certain knowledge
certainly in in the middle to thousands
the district was interested in making
sure that its highways advice was
effective and coordinated we now seek
through planning performance agreements
with applicants to actually recover
highways costs in a way that we've not
done previously and so to that extent I
think we're confident that that's an
ongoing relationship which is building
and the highways recover their costs
indeed throughout charged
pre-application services and indeed that
was a first point that this council
started as an initiative so I'm not sure
what I say I can hold up that on the
detail I've counselor burns you have a
question no it was a supplementary
answer to council Whitehead Johnson to I
some five on the amendment but mr. spell
is just stolen most of my thunder on
that one
the point is that we have long been
willing to explore how highways advice
is provided but the prison arrangements
are considered effective to ensure
timely planning and highways advice is
available obviously it's something the
chief planning officer capes on the
practical review with colleagues at
Suffolk County Council and will continue
to do so Desmond Carter yes so I have
forgotten majority of my question now
however in God's TV I assume was a no
Vance
were given earlier there was a phrase
used shown how much alignment there are
between us I personally love to see the
alignment where is the evidence as to
the alignment s in regards to other
brand partial lip service and saying
we're going to certainly seem to the
same right direction where are we put in
the fine line saying she we are going to
do this and where is the action
especially of the environment of form
hasn't actually properly met yet or
hadn't he saying yet councillor Fleming
would you like to answer this yes I mean
I think it's disingenuous to suggest
that nothing's being done because I
think everyone across the floor knows
that a lot is being done don't you know
I think you're missing quite quite a few
points that are coming out of the work
of the task force and in which you
participates so I think your
communications with your task force
members who really need to be improved a
bit because we have a lot of work that
it will be put forward for approval and
consideration by cabinet the first
tranche of suggestions we anticipate
coming before cabinet in April and I
think we all know that we can't just put
forward suggestions willy-nilly which is
what you tend to be suggesting we can't
put electric vehicle charging points all
over the place without understanding
where they should go and who's going to
be everywhere and also without
understanding whether it's a good thing
there are serious problems with
electrical vehicle charging and battery
disposal all these things need to be
considered and we need a sensible
long-term investment strategy for
getting ourselves clear of the carbon
dependency and that is not doing things
in sort of six months after coming into
the admin
I'm sorry but you're very off-base with
that please my point was actually garden
actual evidence and action going back to
the point where Arden emergency need
needs immediate action and also saying
about the battery disposal there may be
problems with that in the future but if
we're not going to be kidding the
planets with batteries whereas large
currents other vehicles are and we have
five years to actually get this done if
we don't do within five years the damage
is irreversible so we need action now
these are meant to be questions and so
we'll move on to counselor Mr Morrison
thank you
so it's encouraging to hear of this
alignment of dis referring specifically
to amendment number one the proposal for
zero carbon homes is that part of this
alignment was that part of what you're
referring to
we like to answer this
just interesting insofar as actually
item one where it refers to every quote
here 1 million pound upfront capital
funding to borrow against our own house
building program I mean oh well is this
is being put forward as an amendment
under the general fund budget to me that
anyway as I understand it anyway is a
housing revenue account because it
hasn't renewed County's ring-fenced and
that copes with all our council house
building as we'll come on to in the next
item so and also I mean it also talks
about all new housing should be zero
carbon what the question is how
realistic is that now if the next
planning referrals coming to you
somebody puts up forward would that
actually be a sensible proposition in
terms of actually delivering a
large-scale housing you our district
sorry I'm Molly G want to come back
thanks um see ya you ask the question
how feasible is that we recently in talk
arranged by John Matheson how feasible
that is I think there's general
agreement that it is
and yes John can just come back and then
Rachel yeah well I attended that lecture
and I found it most interesting but I
think there was somewhere where he
talked about was it's like 180 thousand
pound a typical house price which
basically went unless you put the London
for free or even less than free you know
still wasn't economically viable that's
what that was my understanding although
I found it very interesting and very
encouraging that's coming with a point
in bettering a notion of house building
Federation the the cost per square meter
of an average build is somewhere between
1800 and 2,000 pounds so I actually made
it a hundred pounds per square per
square meter less okay great see okay
thank you thank you chair I just wanted
to come back on that on answering that
question all homes should be zero carbon
because other councils have shown us as
possible we've had a ward winning scheme
in Norwich for example that one of our
partners that we're now working with was
has been involved with their schemes in
York as I as I mentioned in my
introduction to this amendment so we so
this is being done
you know when then there needs to be
some kind of you know talk about
alignment but there needs to be some
kind of urgency and actually doing
something and using that the funds that
we have available and we are able to
build market housing we can build our
own market housing we can use the seed
pod idea we could use our own that we
could run our own competition for the
idea but these are all of the things
within this amendment have been done by
other councils nothing is is new nothing
is new technology so we just need to
really get get on and do it now I've got
um councillor our mayor and council to
burn up for questions but we're
basically moving into bait let's not
beat about the bush that's what we're
basically doing so shall we just
officially move into debate
oh she won't just ask a question Eric
thank you sure a questioner for council
ebook it's my experience that if you
give someone a job
and then you tell me how to do it you
achieve mediocrity we all voted to
establish climate change task force does
she feel that by bringing these
certainly the first three of the
amendments does she feel that this
undermines the task force or supports it
yes thank you very much chair thank you
for your question councilor mayor of
firstly two observations one the task
force isn't actually going to come
forward with any of its proposals until
after this budget has been signed off
and approved so we won't know any of
that till n in any way but secondly a
lot of this is to do with the business
so Evie charging points in stone work it
people will come into stone market they
will stay because they need to charge up
their cars they will go into the local
shops and businesses and that's a
business proposition Zero Carbon housing
when you have zero carbon housing your
your heating bills are extremely low and
so what that enables people to do is
actually to maybe to take jobs that was
a part-time job where previously then
you had to do a full-time job people
have less that's what stressful lives in
that circumstance so it's a social
outcome for there so there are much
broader outcomes than just environmental
and I think just to try to pin it into
an environmental thing for the task
force is it's not fair on the task force
and plus as we heard from councillor
Fleming there's a huge amount that's
being looked out there to put more into
it
really it's kind of is unfair on them
and I think there's lots of things that
can be done now that we could just agree
today Thank You chair councillor burner
had you down next do you want to ask a
question
no it wasn't question I was just about
to serve anybody three minutes because I
could get David to whether we were in
question of questions and answers or
whether we were in debate
okay well time to be confused situation
okay
councillor minute Thank You chair and as
a member of the Environment task group I
would just like to make a couple of
comments
and I'm sure Casa lumen will be very
pleased to know that I have been keeping
my colleagues on this side of the
chamber very well informed about the
progress sorry Claire since you're up
sandy so now we've moved into debate
we're going to give you three minutes
and everyone has the same time okay just
want to say that this is now debate okay
thank you so so the environment Task
Group has had a number of meetings and
we've had some very interesting
presentations however it seems to me
that we are still some way off coming
through with a set of recommendations
since we started the process back in
October the evidence for manmade climate
change has continued to rack up and if
anything things are now more urgent but
if I refer you to the terms of reference
of the task force it uses words like
urgent act decisively it mentions an
emergency and it talks about completing
our work by the end of March where we're
not actually meeting in March the next
meetings be postponed till April and
then we featured briefly in the
corporate outputs document here where it
talks about early actions coming out in
the winter and then full strategy and
action plan being signed off in the
spring and it doesn't seem to me that
the kind of urgency that we need is
characterized what we've actually been
doing in the task for task force so as
we have some proposal before us in this
amendment and these are not wild ideas
but I think they are sensible measured
proposals I see no reason why these
proposals which we so which the
proposals which we hopefully will come
forward from the task of group will not
complement these that we have before us
today
climate change is developing with the
speed of an Australian bush fire yet we
having declared an emergency are moving
with the speed of a melting glacier
let's get some actions going actions
that will help future-proof mid Suffolk
and so I commend this amendment and I
look for support from all parts of the
chamber thank you
Thank You chair just wanted to go
through this sort of history of this our
proposals as we said before we started
off in November engaging early actually
listening to members criticisms of
previous budget ideas that we've had to
actually make sure they're well costed
that they're legal and actually we've
shared them with the administration a
long way off so any of the rough corners
can be knocked off so it's sort of
disappointing that all this one couldn't
actually been quite easily zoomed into
the budget because you have the
opportunity now I'm going to spend most
of my time focusing on one of the ideas
and surprising it's not the electrical
vehicle ones although I'm very
disappointed with some of the comments
about electric vehicles coming from the
administration today we need to get
together on that and get to the truth of
the matter the competition about housing
plants we this is not purely
environmental and this is the point we
have a number of issues within planning
we have according to Lord deben we're
passing utter crap in terms of housing
design in Suffolk if that's not deep
into quote and environmentally a lot of
stuff that we're approving in we're
building is not up to snuff it's going
to be unsustainable in mortgageable
terms in less than a decade so we need
to get sharp about that we also need to
support our own building industries and
our own suppliers into the building
industry here in Suffolk and in mid
Suffolk so the idea of having the
competition was to knock off that edge
get that Suffolk preservation site
involved so we do design a brilliant
Suffolk design something that's ours not
just off the shelf that's anywhere in
Britain that's something about us if
there is prize money involved in this
for the winning architect but the prize
for us is that those plans then become
open source so if you're going to be
self builder or a small builder your
biggest initial cost from bringing
forward a housing development will be
the cost of the design of the plans
they'll already be designed and you can
have them for free for decades our local
plan housing numbers
it's face has been washed by windfall
and self builders to actually ensure
that happens will mean we hit our
housing delivery targets taking less
stress off our planning policy team and
actually delivering on those housing
outcomes and those housing outcomes will
also be fit for decades to come and not
just for a short term which is why if a
loan you could only support one of these
items are certainly safe you know two
minutes thirty eight them I'm finding it
so yes so even if you can only approve
one please approved just item two happy
to amend any a bit if you need to but I
encourage you to to vote in favor of
this amendment thank you thank you very
much chair I'm sorry that any if
anyone's failing that because we have a
climate change task force that they had
surplus to requirements here the we have
we do have a climate change task force
we have plenty of funding a huge amount
of funding more than a half a million we
can dip into we we need time to get a
profound knowledge and carefully plan
how we're going to attack this emergency
just because it's an emergency
doesn't mean but you run to afar and
click about all over the place you need
to take a careful look that's exactly
what you're doing and make sure you get
the most out of your money there every
single pound is reducing the most carbon
creating the best ecosystems and doing
doing the best further cause that it
possibly can so please just let this
cross-party
task force that's built up of members
all around this chamber get on with
their work and don't take bread out of
her mouth because we will be coming back
to you with some
ambitious and forward-thinking
recommendations very soon thank you then
thank you very much chairman whoops
don't answer back and yeah just a few
other other points I would like to raise
if you look at point one there regarding
potentially putting an extra million
quid upfront I personally am NOT happy
about just sign it off on the basis of
what we have here in front of us it's a
lot of money I'm not saying it's wrong
but I do think we've got to be very
careful just committing a million pound
notes of taxpayers money without being
absolutely sure we know what's gonna be
happening done timescales outputs
deliveries who's going to be responsible
really important we don't run into a
mother with that again I'm not against
the idea but I can't support it just in
that state there just need to know the
details regarding the tongue but some of
the others I think John's already said
many of those can be incorporated anyway
so I would support that on the basis
that if they're going to be included we
don't need to need to deal with this the
other thing I'm just if I could
elaborate on the electrical points I
wasn't trying to say we shouldn't do it
the new technology I forget what it's
actually called the really fast charging
systems you get now do we are we
absolutely sure we've got the right
infrastructure
I just want reassurance design
capabilities well I'm you're saying that
I know they're getting I get it but I do
think if we're going to commit money to
it we need to be absolutely sure and I'm
not doing this to kick it into the long
grass or delay it let's make sure we've
got the terms of reference suspect
future-proof it of course that's so it
can be extended I'm not an engineer I
don't know what you need to do to that
and so on so we need to make sure we're
doing the right thing so I'm not against
it but I do think on the basis of this
it can be included and with the task
group looking at this certainly ozone to
get on with it as quickly as possible
it is the sensible thing to do and the
last point about the help on the
highways again what are the terms of
reference what is the issue we're trying
to deal with quantify it with some
evidence and data before we commit
putting money into anything we need to
be a bit more precise and I do know
there's a lot of liaison now with a
county sure we can always improve it we
can always improve everything but let's
be sensible about it let's get on with
these things yes but I don't know that
we
to support the amendment to do it
because if most of this work has been
done in any case and we can get it from
resources within the existing budget
well that's what we should do but I am
worried about that million pound notes
for that that one number one I would
urge members to be very careful when
they consider how to vote on this for
that reason councillor Richardson
thank you very much chair firstly if I
can just touch very briefly upon the
question of alignment I think it is
important to remember the wider
perspective on this that we have had
discussions for a number of months and
although there are particular objections
around these specific amendments we have
incorporated an enormous amount of the
original suggestions into the budget
itself so I think that's where the
Alliance comes from and I have to say
I'm not going to reiterate a number of
the points that have already been made
but there is actually one point that
after council stringer spoke I just want
to sort of touch upon with regards to
this competition because I'm not
entirely clear how this would work in
practice so I appreciate cancer stream
you've already spoken but if that's fact
to be addressed by either the proposal
or the second I had welcomed some
clarification on this because my
understanding of what's being proposed
is that architects produce does a design
or designs that would then win this
competition and that would then become
the basis for a sort of lot of the Shelf
models we use across the county come at
the point I would just sort of
rhetorically make is what then becomes
of the intellectual property for those
designs does that sit with the architect
or can anyone use it and if that is the
case what the council noticed so what is
the incentive for architects to
participate in this if they can win
20,000 pounds if I were a commercial
developer architect I think that was a
bit of a waste of money if I'm honest
and I'm not quite sure that's the kind
of I agree that there are improvements
we can make to design in-house building
across the county that I'm just not sure
this is the way forward and if we are to
incorporate the is sort of the
underlying motivations behind this I'd
much rather we go away think that
properly and come back with some wall
for a bottle proposals and so in that
basis on the food I can't support this
amendment Thank You cows for geek
Thank You chair and we have heard
tonight from counselors opposite that
infrastructure must be able to support
our needs and therefore we must support
a road building program the a14
expressway but we've also heard that we
cannot provide the infrastructure for
electric vehicles because the technology
may become a they may become out-of-date
or because it's difficult and we don't
understand it we've also heard from
councillor whitehead that an emergency
may not be a dangerous situation
requiring immediate action and one of
the main requirements of agreeing that
we are in a crisis is that we must act
as if this crisis is real so surely a
budget setting meeting must act as if
the crisis is real these proposals this
amendment then it's not kicking a fire
about they're an essential minimum a
start and there is expertise among
officers there's expertise among the
members on this side please can we not
let a lack of understanding defeat us
councillor Brewster thank chairman yes
we've heard a lot about electric
charging points and we're doing nothing
about it can I just read you a few notes
here the administration's ambition is
not just to approach this by installing
evey charging points but to broaden this
out to explore the best approach getting
people into electric vehicles overall
hence the broadest description in the
corporate plan outputs we currently have
an e V charging point at Neyland Lake we
are due to install one at I
there is scoping going on for the Regal
car park and still market as soon as the
and that would probably be something
like 4050 weeks I daresay and but it's
after we're regenerating the car park
there and we need to do that to get the
power coming into it so that is being
scoped at the moment we are currently
identifying a list of further potential
sites across the district we're
exploring a solar carport project
initially for still market leisure
center this will in time not
only offer many Eevee points but we'll
also be able to deliver carbon savings
to our leisure centers through battery
storage and solar regeneration or solar
generation this would be a better
investment and if successful after a
trial period could be installed in other
car parks across the district which
reduces pressure on the grid and the
need to fund substantial power stations
bus power installations
we're also researching partnering with
companies such as a Eno charging or BP
charge master to install III points in
more of our car parks we will be
promoting the government scheme where
car owners can get a discount on the
price of brand-new low emission vehicles
through a grant the government provides
to vehicle dealerships and manufacturers
maximum grant being three thousand five
hundred the cost of e V charge points
vary considerably depending on the type
of charger rapid charge is being the
most expensive of course and the
proximity of the proximity of the power
source we've installed similar fast we
well we will be installing similar fast
charges which have a cost of around
13,000 to twenty thousand the difference
due to the connection cost charged by UK
Power Networks greens have previously
arranged licensing fee reduction of 10%
for electric vehicle taxes this would
work out at approximately 30 pounds per
license it would cost approximately 3500
to mid Suffolk in loss of income but
it's also likely it's been to be an
unlikely to be an incentive in part
because the saving on the license fee
would be considerably outweighed by the
high cost of easy vehicles at present we
are working on it
Kerris Llywelyn Thank You chair I'd like
to talk a bit about their need for
highway expertise I would like to give
an example I attended a Bashan meeting
recently the traffic impact assessment
for that application took me about 12
hours to work through it yeah I'm a sad
person if I spend that amount of time on
time but I didn't and I found glaring
errors in it and I explained those to
the development control committee
Suffolk County Council had not found
them and there was no highways officer
present and I also think we're missing
out on highway improvements ending up
with Trump and we're ending up with
traffic and safety risks we could have
avoided think of the coop in snow upland
where people have been injured on the
first day of term in September to church
to children were injured and yet the
County highways officer had said it was
safe I don't think so so it would appear
to me that we don't have enough or
Suffolk County Council don't have the
resource to provide a proper service to
us now one of my wishes when being
elected to this council was to see real
improvements to the center of stone
market I've said this four times now
including a wider range of shopping
opportunity within the town center a
broad range of nighttime leisure
opportunities public art improved
streetscape better pedestrian facilities
safe cycling through and around and to
and from snow market good links to
nearby settlements including community
and public transport which is attractive
and cheap or free to use we need to
encourage people to stay in snow market
for an hour or two this could be by
providing free parking after three
o'clock on Monday a week introducing EB
points could encourage electric car
users to spend time and money in stone
market
we hear some of these ideas are being
taken up but it's important we do it now
when will we see proposals for improving
stone market and and our district-wide
residents perception of stone mark is
that there is not a good perception of
stone market across the district people
will go to Ipswich or berry or somewhere
else rather than stone market and we've
got to change that we've got to improve
the perception and show what's there
market has to offer our proposals will
benefit the economy the economy and
environment of stone market and can and
encourage residents to shop local rather
than drive you to Barry or elsewhere and
that will it reduce the carbon entering
the atmosphere if we don't have evey
points people with electric cars will go
elsewhere to shop these are five quick
wings these five in the amendment and I
commend every aspect of this amendment
to everyone in the chamber castor Carter
thank you I'd like to use my free
minutes regarding one aspect Mays B zero
carbon housing we've heard regarding
where's the incentive before if we get
this standard out there where it be in
sense of B for people to apply for it
well I'd argue is what's it going to
cost us to find out if we actually put
this initiative out there as opposed to
what would the benefit be if it actually
pays off and we do have this standard of
affordable housing and often
environmentally friendly housing we have
a lot more to gain than we could
possibly lose I would also like to point
out facts the number of councils that
have now with the players very clans
mergency now stands at 261 I will admit
out of those two and 61 60 of them
already have a burst of their own zero
carbon schemes passive hauser ones prior
to them
if they come on in that necrosis yet
would you be aware about 20 of those
since amounts in a climate crisis have
put forward very zero carbon housing
schemes why are we not one of them we
are we are part of a heart of Suffolk we
are supposed to be Suffolk they know
because we green it's County yeah I see
little evidence of it I've run a name so
I don't see any I don't see how
foolishly put in this wood I don't see a
down forward socially being a leader
rather an follower so why can't we cut
off though why can't we action rather
than just say we're going to action and
actually go for schemed that's not going
to cost us anything but completely save
the world
thank you Thank You councillor Massa
Thank You Chet yes I must say the the
the I'm afraid I'd have to call those
slightly nitpicking points from various
members opposite these proposals have
been in discussion with the
administration since November so there's
been about 10 or 12 weeks to to sort out
any precise details that have been
wanted and really just to say that the
you know it is now a climate emergency
and if you look back a dozen years or so
there was a family called Lord Nicholas
Stern and an economist who he suggested
the investment in of a small amount of
our gross domestic product in addressing
climate change a dozen years ago and if
if we'd have actually followed his
advice nationally and locally then it
would be an emergency now unfortunately
it is an emergency now so what I would
say to you is look don't let the best
the precise getting it right the best
the enemy of the good
we need to good get on with it thank you
thank you I've got an cancer scarf
thank you I'd like to speak to the free
parking in stone market this council on
a regular basis for special events in
stone market issues free parking for
residences to both the surrounding area
and stone market to come in and support
their business in stone market that is
to be congratulated
however there is a cost to that in that
we lose car park revenue what we're
proposing here which is one day a week
after 3 p.m.
would give every week people the ability
to come into town and to spend their
money when we offer free parking in
stone market does this council actually
come back to this a wider membership and
actually say well it's going to cost us
five thousand pounds for the day do we
have your permission no they don't but
we have a cost of proposal here which we
know is going to cost us thirty thousand
pounds it's a drop in the ocean against
the car park income which is six hundred
and sixty one thousand pounds I think
that figure is a very high figure and is
largely borne by stone market residents
so I would make a plea why don't we just
do something to support the stone market
local economy this is not going to cost
us a lot of money we've put in a
situation here where we're prepared to
review it in due course we're not saying
to do it forever we need to see whether
it works and I cannot see why members
opposite would not support just that one
element of the five points within this
amendment thank you person of Pratt
Thank You chair I don't want to
reiterate too many points but I feel
that you know since our electors have
elected a 50% Lib Dem and green
councillors it would be slightly perhaps
Democratic deficit to totally disregard
the proposals put here since they were
put forward by the joints parties and I
think that you know if there is
alignment as you say there is Council of
Whitehead then perhaps you could specify
exactly from from what here you you are
taking forward and what you would like
to disregard and just propose an
amendment to this motion and so it can
be voted through and now what I would
also like to say is that I can accept
that the climate and environment task
and finishing the group it is working
hard and and I'm really looking forward
to seeing some more detailed proposals
come through and I hope that one of
those is going to be you know on things
that things that we can viably do for
example putting electric vehicle
charging points and the taxi ranks so
that we could speed up the phasing out
of of petrol and diesel taxis in the
very near future and and I just want to
make a quick point as well about the
financial disincentive you know the
spending of one and a half million from
from the budget on this well I think
that it's quite small bear considering
that we're investing nine million I
think it is in a property trading
company which is neither the ream it's
all the purpose of council what we're
proposing here is adding value to the
services that the council are supposed
to be providing for our citizens and so
I wish I hope that you can consider that
as well and yeah thank you very much can
step in your
oops huh sure I really want to speak up
on behalf of Stowe market because I'm
heartily fed up of counselors running it
down over on that side of the room Stowe
market is a great town Stowe market is a
great town I'll have you know I am a
citizen of Stowe market
I live in stone market I shop in still
market there are many things to
recommend stock market of course
Stowe market like every town up and down
the country has its problems you know
with online shopping and the like and as
so does Barry so does it switch so
there's no Nirvana that says if you go
in those two directions and you'll be
saved we are working very hard with our
vision for posterity developing the
Museum of East Anglian life to be a
National Museum of food we've just
launched an innovation hub by the
station
we're redeveloping the Regal and then we
will have some electric new charging
points there chaps and unlesss we have a
quite a successful football club that's
developing very nicely thank you very
much so and we're developing the middle
school for affordable housing so we have
a lot of good things going on in stock
market and we could have more and no
one's denying that fact
sorry encourage everybody to look on the
bright side you know our glass is
half-full and stomach is going places
thank you is there anyone else that
would like to speak so when we can go
back to oh sorry I'm seized and
counselor morning
Thank You Jer with regard to the
proposed 1 million upfront capital
funding to borrow against for our own
house building this really requires a
lot more investigation it is not obvious
that the general fund can contribute to
the HRA stock in this way but officers
are exploring whether the general fund
can legally fund the additionality that
would make new hair council housing
carbon 0 also carbon 0 is not required
as part of our planning policy and we
cannot require an approach where all new
housing is carbon neutral also when it
comes to taxes
you mentioned taxes we don't actually
have any taxes that are electric and we
only have two private hire vehicles that
are electric so installing major
infrastructure in terms of electric
vehicle charging for tech specifically
for taxis in advance of the requirement
is clearly a waste of our taxpayers
money there seems to be some sort of
misunderstanding we are not arguing
against these proposals because we
disagree with them we are arguing
against them because we are already
doing some of this stuff and scoping it
and our officers are working their
little socks off to get all this
information together and to have after
all the discussions that we've had to
have these proposals come forward
undermining the work of the task force
and negating all the goodwill that has
been generated to date between this side
of the chamber and the opposition teams
I find really really distressing because
it's it goes against every
things that our residents should be
expecting from us thank you
I just like to clear up a little
misunderstanding which sure to people on
the other side of the room seem to have
got about our item number one we are not
talking about HR a funded council houses
we are talking about market homes in
which case we are perfectly within our
rights to use our general fund to put to
to provide market housing we're not
talking about HRA we're not talking
about transfer and I think the other
point that counsel mall is just made up
about just spoken about where does this
some one-and-a-half million upfront
costs come from and our general fund
can't can't do that I'm sorry we have
still have that 9.2 million in our
reserves that's where the money is
coming from it's not coming out of our
general budget that was required for
other things there's one other
misunderstanding that perhaps I've got
in that I thought that the the proposal
council wire heads original proposal
talked about five hundred thousand for
the actions from the task group and then
council cast and said it was more than
that so that's a little misunderstanding
I've got maybe
yes Lee burns you want to wrap this up
will not wrap it up so you know I'm
saying thank you very thank you very
much to tear firstly I just want to
clear up a few points that various
members have made councillor Brewster I
think you referred to a previous version
of the amendment about taxi licensing
that that's not included in in this
point and the on the EEV policy the evie
points within the corporate outputs that
refers to policy not not actually action
of putting points in place councillor
Mansell's mentioned about market homes
and councillor Richardson you mentioned
about what's in it for architects well
we spoke to architects about the plan
and they think the kudos are providing
those plans would be just fantastic and
would add a good swing to their their
bows so we have actually talked to
people but firstly I'm sorry I don't
want to distress councillor morally
because I think that we've what we've
done here tonight and what we've seen
from this debate I mean this has been
fantastic look at the discussions that
we've been having well on what happens
when we have kind of good ambitious
forward-thinking ideas put forward that
have been planned out that have got to
we've had legal look at them we've had
finance look at them I mean it's great
to see to see so much debate and what we
really need to do is actually to do this
you know we're not waiting for
technology we're not looking at long
term strategy I think someone's talked
about doing some more research you know
let's just let's just do some of this
and let's just get it into the into the
main part of the budget and do it with
regards to kind of how we have worked
together some ideas have gone forward
into the into the budget and into the
corporate outputs and these are these
are some ones which we have also been
working up with officers and with
members which can equally go into the
budget and actually really move forward
our district I like to stay market I
shopping to do market but what we're
saying is about how we're improving how
we want to get more people
in there and not people have gone to
different towns in in Ipswich in Barrie
and actually all we want to do is
improve the quality of life for our
residents and businesses help
future-proof our district and put
forward well-thought-out ambitious
proposals and I really would commend
this to all of you here and I again I
just like to reiterate it's so fantastic
to see so many contributions from
everybody across the room
Thank You chair councillor whitehead do
you want some reply would you like to
know I think in my instruction where I
was saying no I went into quite a lot of
detail I think I said okay so in
accordance with council procedure rule
19.3 immediately after any vote was
taken at a budget decision meeting of
the council including any amendments the
names of the councillors who cast a vote
for the decision or against the decision
or who abstained from voting shall be
recorded in the minutes of that meeting
and I will ask John Robinson to conduct
this Thank You chair just to be clear we
are on we are voting on the amendment if
you can answer me with four against or
abstain counselor and Morrison Council
Brewster okay councillor burn councillor
Carter or counts the Caston councillor
Eban count stepping on counts of field
counts of Flatman councillor Fleming
yeah councillor geek counts of gold
counts for Guthrie counts for having
them against counts for Hicks counts for
Humphries cancer Mansell councillor
Madison count some melon councillor
mayor council Morni councillor Muller
council Norris Council autumn
helps to pass small house the Pratt
Council Richardson counts the scarf
counts the strainer or counts to Turner
council war boys councillor Willam
counts a white head thank you so that
was lost for 17 to 16 so we're going to
we're going to return to the original
motion for debate and and start the
debate again so we would like to speak
first so we are going into questions so
this is questions - um Shawn if you if
you've got any apparently been done
thank you very much chair think
everybody wants a coffee break after
that one but perhaps not perhaps not
coffee
anyway um something locally just do um
Mike my questions um if I may the spend
of the on intense bond paragraph seven
point six the spend of the five hundred
thousand for the climate change could
you confirm that spenders plan to be
made in twenty twenty twenty one and
secondly with regards to the eight
paragraph eight fourteen there's no
increased forecast at all for business
rates over the next four years
could you just explain this please thank
you Jeff in terms of five hundred
thousand we're allocating and putting in
the budget with twenty twenty-one this
would be spent as of when it comes for
and if I actually said I've said it's a
start or anyway but to actually say
commit to spending the total he's caught
between now and the end
March class next year will depend on how
it's all brought forward but certainly
as far as I would be concerned if it
wasn't all spent next year but there's
still requirements it would be carry
forward but intention is that that is
after the impound but should be needed
will be needed and it's the starting
position for our work on climate change
and in terms of business rates we my
understanding is at the moment of
government it's just basically indicated
what business rates position will be
through to the end of March 2021 but
they're still in the process of
redesigning the problem probably quite
difficult Lee the business rate
situation so at the moment we just put
in the same figure going forward because
we don't know anything better is that
right cut
is there any more questions for John or
should we move straight to debate
councillor Weller Thank You chair yes
director John okay councillor Whitehead
is it your view that government
introduced new homes bonus so that
councils could stash it away if all
councils behaved in the same fashion
why would government not remove it
councils basically I think to sort of
spending this sort of day-to-day stuff I
call the normal running costs and then
the special costs are special projects
would offer transfer transformation I
mean western new his bonus was
originally put into this what we call
the transformation fund and a lot of it
was spent in terms of that you were
working together process and indeed
moving from the two half used high
energy sites in favor and reciprocal and
moving down to showing this public
sector space here so the a lot of
councils I think did have to use new
hands bonus just to balance their book
as I said in my talk before because of
the robust situation we've been in and
continued
and we've been in a situation where we
haven't had to use up the day-to-day
expending being able to use it for all
sorts of projects and I believe the fact
the government and now taking it away to
suggest that it's not there for day to
day counselor field thank you I think my
question just got asked you know most
identical words so I won't go on cancer
often yes it's a question on paragraph
seven point seven on your reserves and
then a statement there that says there
is nothing about what is in the SIL pot
and I am very surprised at that I would
have thought that there should be at
least some indication of the quite
frankly enormous amount of money sitting
in the civil pot and I'd also like to
have some information there have been
206 silk exemptions so can I be assured
that the council is fulfilling its legal
duty under the self-build and Custom
House Building Act 2015 to maintain an
up-to-date register of plots available
for self builders I believe that is this
is a legal requirement and I know this
is possibly not the only council that is
failing to provide that list burden it's
on the capital program disabled
facilities grants I know and I'm pleased
actually that this council has adopted a
much more cando can-do attitude to these
but either can you or the cabinet member
for housing assure us that the contract
which
appears to be failing is going to
deliver much better in the future and it
will be looked at much more seriously
thank you thank you just well trust
three up I'll defer there's the third
one actually to councillor Flatman but
some it tells the SIL and in the in the
taking the table shown there I think
it's important that we show the total
reserves as a subtotal and then show SIL
separately because that really is money
that's collected from our developers to
use specifically for community
infrastructure and goes through a very
specific process I mean quite frankly I
think I personally would if I could
we're actually just keeping totally out
out of this report because to me it is
just a completely separate things but
the reality is I think there's the paper
coming to cabinet in March and yet
another round of spend and the we were
told at the start that actually the
amount of Silla money raised will
probably be inadequate for the total
amount of the infrastructure needless
that we've always will all be spent but
at this stage particularly for next year
we just can't crystal ball gaze and put
a real number in there but it will be
spent as the bids come in
well actually I'm really sorry to hear
you say that you wouldn't even want to
have it included this is money that is
being put aside for the public as a
result in many cases enormous planning
applications and therefore I think they
have a right as a public to know how
much is sitting there in order to for
them to access that to help them through
some quite traumatic situations sorry
it is so clearly separate and ring-fence
but to me it it is its own subject
so I'm not saying it should be hitting
away and it should be basically it it's
not it's just not a reserve that really
fits that so I have to be past that as
well saying it's to something the public
domain online anywhere but the in terms
of the sill exemptions and the question
you raised there which is quite a
technical question I think I might we
throw that to an officer reprobate if
there's a relevant officer present who
could could answer that I mean I assume
a compliance any hope so but third
officer to say that rather than myself
as I'm eating we're gonna take this out
you know another time outside the
meeting okay um I've got one councillor
burn do you want to ask a question I'm
sorry John back house apartment
as you know the adaption reduction grant
has just been changed with up to seven
thousand on liens and up to forty
thousand means-tested but not for
children
so people need in wet rooms etc we are
quite right it's up three new that's
contract and we're but forget it very
close so I can't say any more than that
because it's not in the public domain
yet
thank you I'm cancelling burns you have
a question
a white man is answering the questions
about the silver okay feel safe you're
satisfied to take it out that's fine are
there any other questions for counselor
white head counselor Carter my dance
moves over here
made me move a bit away from my desk or
intended dad right sorry this is also
regards to did their they're dead the
disabled adaptation fund and I just
wanted some reassurance regarding the
delays being faced by that I didn't know
if you were aware that the this fund has
been delayed due to the occupational
therapist be it way to being up to two
years they are saying part of that to
haven't spoken to occupational therapist
perversion was saying that's a part of
that weight is actually struggling with
communication with our offices we
eidetic very and interest I am also on
the waiting list for past year for their
can we be as reassured that this is
being addressed especially yes I believe
it was four years ago we were talking
about employing our own occupational
therapists to address this and has yet
have done nothing to do douzo
[Music]
okay so throwing g12 answers well you've
got a question yes okay I am I would
like to say counselor that in a
different capacity as a chair of Health
scrutiny if I'd like to see you
afterwards so or communicate with you
because that's simply not good enough I
would like to make sure that you get the
disabled support that you need there's
absolutely no reason why you should
perience a daily delay like this there
are some problems with the delivery of
the of the disabled facilities grants
that the council country council and the
districts are working on and I think
we're going to see some fundamental
changes to the delivery of that service
in the near future there are problems
there have been problems with the
contractor delivering it and I make you
know no apologies for that but I would
like to speak to you afterwards about
your particular situation so we're gonna
move to debate who would like to begin
the debate he has lyrics brilliant thank
you very much madam chairman and budget
day I've said on I think about six
different occasions at a time really
across the whole of the country when all
councilors come together and it's when
we need to really reflect on the
enormous responsibility that we've all
been given by the residents of myth
soffit particularly today because now we
decide the future direction of this
authority for the coming year and that
is a really important and significant
time and we also need to determine how
we're going to spend our budget now we
need to reflect I think that our party
the Conservative Party has just been
returned to government with a huge
majority and why is that because we have
a track record of managing the economy
well we have a track record of putting
together a detailed a structured a
deliverable and a sustainable budget you
have and I've said those key lines
before only a few weeks ago but we did
win a huge majority because we have a
track record I don't believe there is
more than one member of the Greens in
Parliament could you let me finish my
speech and be polite
thank you now the papers before us are
very clear over the year since 2011 to
2020 this council has achieved
cumulative savings
under 31 million pounds and that is
through shared services through
efficiencies through better use of
technology and maximizing commercial
opportunities and we should be proud
that we have achieved that that is a
great accomplishment and that is because
we're a well-run Council and a prudent
counsel and that along with the
forecasts of 2.8 million identified for
2021 I mean we're in a good position but
we must not be complacent we do not know
and cannot know what lies ahead but this
Authority has always shown it can adapt
and I have no doubt with a conservative
administration it will continue to do so
in the future and I am delighted to see
the principles that are laid out on page
43 of our papers about reducing our
costs increasing our income providing
better and best value increasing social
value and providing a better service for
our residents and reducing
administration costs without
compromising service madam chairman I'd
like to conclude by asking members to
support this budget because it focuses
on the needs of our residents and I'm
really glad that we have set aside
funding to start the delivery on the
climate change emergency this budget is
well considered it's sustainable and it
focuses on the needs of our residents
and I hope you'll all support it Thank
You Chancellor Fleming
yes Thank You chairman thank you very
much mmm I too am pleased to support
this general fund budget this evening it
reflects a prudent and principled
approach to managing our ie the Suffolk
public sub mid Suffolk public's money
and we should not forget that it is
their money that is entrusted to us it's
not ours as castle Hicks has mentioned I
take the principles that this this
council has adopted seriously
particularly providing service to our
customers and including social
environmental value and everything we do
for the first time this budget
anticipates investment targeted directly
to climate change and biodiversity half
a million at least in this particular
budget is earmarked from reserves as
we've already pointed out exactly what
projects will be identified as
beneficiaries of this money will come
out through the task force work this
work has to assess the large number of
possibilities that have been put before
us prioritize and put resources to where
they will be most effectively used we
are going to be hearing some initial
reports about where those priorities lie
this March and we will be bringing a
formal report to cabinet on the climate
change aspects of the work in April we
expect to bring the biodiversity
elements which are also part of our
terms of reference into this work that
on an ongoing basis the task force is
nothing to stop its work in April it
will need funding and commitment as I
see it in the foreseeable future I would
add this important budget marks the
beginning of a new approach to direct
investment in the environment we haven't
seen this before this is
an important first step and one which I
believe is supported by most of our mid
suffer presidents therefore I commend
and support this budget this evening if
anyone else like to speak castor eBay
thank you very much chair like some of
my own friends and colleagues often sit
I find myself getting up to say the same
thing year after year but I think that
that's not me and firstly members
opposite of referred about not being
complete complacent well I I don't want
us to be complacent I would like us to
be delivering a really strong
forward-thinking budget for all of our
residents people have told us our
communities have told us that they want
planning resolved in their communities
they want support from this district
they want to be able to future-proof
their homes for their children and their
and their grandchildren and I don't feel
that this budget goes far enough in
terms of meeting those needs of our
residents and as such I will not be
supporting this budget today we have
large sums set aside which i think is a
quote from from one of my colleagues
opposite 9.2 3 5 million at the moment
that we are said we are stockpiling and
we should be spending on some
initiatives to really ensure that we can
future-proof MIT Suffolk for all
residents and businesses so I would like
to see us actually utilizing this
funding every year we talk about new
homes bonus and money going into
reserves and it continues to sit there
we need to get that money out working
hard for our residents and businesses
and this budget does not go far enough
to meet that and finally chair I just I
wouldn't want to disappoint you what
you're an independent member of the
administration
being labeled a conservative so it's
just to not to leave him out of the out
of the loop here reassure him that he's
he's not a conservative but anyway on
that note at night on that note I would
like I wish that we know more of our
ideas could be taken forward and I do
look forward to working with the
administration to do that
and welcome meetings at the earliest
opportunity to take some of those ideas
forward but at the moment I feel we're
not going far enough in this budget and
there's so much more that we could be
doing Thank You chair councilor field
thank you sure this is interesting
yeah the high competence of conservative
administration's be admired black Black
Monday was the thing that was passing
across my mind I seem to remember that
being ultimately disastrous in fact you
got to the point where you wondered
whether you'd ever get back in power
again as I remember it that's aside from
this this this area here and this year
we've charged with partial success some
cost party discussion an agreement and
we obviously welcome that I think it was
a good experience
despite tonight's debate did we still
have issues that we need to bring to
your attention in a formal setting I
think um probably perhaps the answers
yes we still do not agree with boring
some 50 million to invest in high-speed
high street properties and car
dealership premises it's currently
yielding a good return
but those areas of the economy are in
increasing trouble and we think the
downside risk is too high
he's the point of which we different we
were now the second point and I'll stick
to just a couple is are we doing enough
to address our common emergency
declaration are there plans in place to
do better than we're doing now should
there be a clearer way forward in this
but
and I think there's a just stick to a
couple of illustrations the budget could
prepare the way for replacement waste
vehicles that use carbon fuel
electricity from renewable sources
it actually has got in years a figure
for such replacement but you show the
investment in a trial perhaps
insufficient funds for the high cost of
batteries
kamilly packs 300 kiya vehicle in the
future 30k by the time we replace and I
haven't seen those figures I'm quite
aware that we have a in environment
change working party but the figures are
not in the budget unless you get them
there you can't use them the second
thing I had was really work on our
leisure centres we're doing some
excellent work on a new new contracts
which will have a lot of benefits as we
see them now it's a good long-term deal
to improve people's fitness but does a
refurbishment address the issue of co2
generation
he says some coming plan not one that
we've seen there maybe but not one we've
seen should the cost of ground source
heat for instance investigation appear
now and the capital cost it might be a
year or two I don't see anything of that
time I won't go on it's getting late I
think you know I'd sum this up it's a
it's a good try it could be a lot more
ambitious someone we regret to believe
we won't be sitting here can't sleep
thank you sure I listened with interest
to council Hicks his views so I'd like
to apologize to him for my audible
astonishment I'd also like to point out
that all mainstream economic opinion has
challenged the conservative policy on
austerity shrinking the economy further
when in recession as the Conservatives
did from 2010 onwards is economically
illiterate and clearly ideologically
driven also putting our taxpayers money
and to 90 percent reserves for a rainy
day when there is no more rainy day than
now is also ideologically driven we have
known since the beverage report in 1942
if you look at the chapter called the
problem of rent that prosperity has a
firm footing only if there is sufficient
housing you will also all know from the
Redfern review which I hope you're all
familiar with that there is a housing
surplus in this country the reason that
we have a housing crisis is that our
housing stock is not spread equally it
is hoarded by those who owned several
houses and read at the Mount the only
way to undercut this and to stop the
hemorrhage of public money to private
landlords is to bring more housing back
into social rent as a temporary measure
on the step to more owner occupation
which I'm sure many of of all of us
would agree is wanted by most of our
residents and this process would speed
up if zero-carbon measures allowed more
money to be spent on saving for the
deposit
rather than heats in your house to try
again there is no more dangerous
argument than then there is no more
dangerous argument than running a
country is like running a household
something which the conservative
national governments trot out over and
over again sadly this economic miss
prudence
seems to have spread to this
administration so I cannot support this
budget and would urge the rest of you to
think hard about what you're doing
[Applause]
councillor stringer Thank You Chet I
won't go into anything to do with
national politics we really shouldn't do
that at a District Council and that's
really really difficult it's very
difficult to realize we're representing
a very rural part of the country we're
in a glass edifice in a large town but I
can certainly overcome that to trot out
about what's happened at a general
election what the government is doing is
frankly irrelevant look at what's in
this chamber look at what the people
delivered to this chamber they delivered
a council an equal proportion here you
know look at it look at it it's almost
equally split therefore our proposal of
trying to run could join the
administration it's actually quite good
to see that some of the measures that we
would have brought forward as a minimum
as a minimum have been taken account of
and actually put into some of the budget
however some other measures aren't in
there and neither are there measures to
address some of those burning desires of
the people that elect us cutely aware
that someone in this chamber said you
shouldn't put out negatives without at
least five positives I can't quite find
five but one positive I congratulate
John Whitehead as being someone in the
Conservatives in charge of the budget
there's actually able to deliver a
budget well done for that surviving that
long it's brilliant I also wanted to
just sort of mention some of the things
that aren't in here that we would like
to have been in here we would have quite
a logic on far further and others are
and they're reaping those rewards this
hook up about a few charging points in
slow market is is a real symptom of
where we're getting bogged down go to
Dundee
you can only license a zero-emission
taxi in Dundee and they've already built
the solar-powered battery storage and
charging point for all of those taxi
drivers huge resistance to it the start
they took a strategic approach clear
vision of how to get to where they
wanted to go and they've got there and
and are the public moaning
no they think it's absolutely brilliant
and the taxi drivers think it's
brilliant they have free fuel for their
cars while they're waiting for their
next fare
that's a visionary approach and we ought
to adapt it for ourselves particularly
as we have one of the best charging
company manufacturers in our largest
talent yet we have no ongoing rap all
with them they're not involved in any of
the things that we're doing we really
need to do better we've got the
resources here to do that and we should
be improving them all that one of the
biggest complaints I certainly get it's
not about my political ambitions it's
it's about the design of our houses and
if we're completely comfortable with
what the national builders elect to give
us that's the same as everywhere else in
the country stay as you are but the idea
of the competition thing that you've
decided not to agree to put on your
budget I think you need to look at again
seriously because if that's the minutes
now thank you I'm now wrapping up we are
residents want something that's of us
are not just given to us so I'm really
disappointed that you disagree with that
but it will not stop me promoting their
argument further Thank You councillor
Richardson thank you very much chair and
I'm only gonna be brief you'll be
pleased today this is the first budget
speech that I've participated in I have
to say I think this budget adopts
exactly the right approach it is keeping
council tax as low as feasibly possible
while continuing to deliver high-quality
public services and ensuring we invest
in our future I think it's important to
look at these figures and take them into
perspective what we are proposing is a
rise of 1.6 6% which sits significantly
below the growth in average earnings
which sits about 2.9 percent as of the
third quarter of this financial year and
the rate of inflation which is 1.8
percent as of last month I think it's
important we recognize that than what we
are proposing is very modest increase in
council tax because we should remember
and recognize that across the country
low
government finances are particularly
challenged I think that's why it's
especially important that we are
continuing to sustain or planning to
sustain a balanced budget over the
medium term over the next four years
without the need to rely on the new
homes bonus so I think that the whole
this is a budget that recognizes the
challenges that we face across the
district that responds to those
challenges whilst maintaining this
conservative and independent
administration's reputation for the
responsible management of our finances
and for that reason I would commend this
budget to the council and encourage all
councillors to vote in favor of it
councillor Carter yeah sorry yeah
unfortunately I won't you know to
support this mainly because a lot of its
referred to as ours being focused on
climate change and how it's been dealt
with by the environment and forum and
how its we should just let them get on
with it well I think kind of feel
concerns that we are trying to
pigeonhole climate change and trying to
fit under be a listen from the forms of
opinion but we can throw a little bit of
money up and we can train it to dance
until it with tricks because he's a
little bit I'm taking I want it's we we
have no to say over what climate change
does to us
we eat that we're hearing can only act
now and hope we have done enough we
can't do now and say we're going to get
this back from it we've got we are - I
do wonder how much we are focusing on
leisure housing business wonderful great
how much housing how much business how
much leisure
will there be on a dead planet you only
have we only have now
to act this is the budget for the next
four years and it's meant to be one year
okay one year one year when we're
supposed to be acting now we were told
to act now by the IPCC two years ago
where's the action we're talking about
it we're saying it's going to get done
we're gonna throw some money at it
wonderful
where's the action so afraid it can't
support you could turn me off thinking
up counselor what do you want to UM
Brown this up
thank you madam chairman um the UM
actually very proud of the budget is
being brought forward today and I think
it is a budget for the medium-term
continue with our strengths and at the
same time it recognized this the climate
change and but I'm conscious of time so
all I would say to all members here is
that I hope you will support our budget
thank you okay we will again take the
recorded vote whichever chance and is
going to do Thank You chair okay again
this is for the whole budget
recommendations so if you can answer for
against or abstain counselor and
Morrison council Brewster or
counts to burn count so Carter cancer
Kirsten counselor burn cancer Epping on
counts of field counts the Flatman
Council Fleming
that's a geek that's of gold counts of
Guthrie counts for heading him for Tyler
Hicks cancer Humphries that's a mansell
yes
that's the Matteson count some melon
counts the mayor council morning Oh
councillor Muller
council Norris house the Otton counts
the past small or counts of Pratt
Council Richardson counts the scarf
counts of stringer Casa Turner halves of
wool boys house to Wellum counts the
white head so once that is carried I'm
so moving on to UM agenda item 11 MC 19
/ 39 the housing revenue accounts
budgets and longer-term outlook I would
like to invite councilor head again to
introduce his paper and move the
recommendation in the report thank you
madam chairman I shall keep this
interruption below five minutes or do my
best
the HRA has been through a challenging
period in its budget for the year 2021
has a deficit of five hundred sixty four
thousand funded from reserves
I do believe however that is important
to recognize there'd be many positive
developments improvements commenced
during this current year the rising from
a fundamental review of the housing
services that was undertaken in 2019 20s
I identified savings efficiencies and
income-generating opportunities to
achieve a sustainable business plan for
the future these achievements identified
opportunities are set out in detail
section seven and eight of the report
turning now to some of the details
included within report recommendations
from April 20 we are now allowed to
increase castle house rents by consumer
price index plus 1% which works out at
2.7 percent increase
there must be aware that over the past
four years the government's imposed
every and every one of those years or
one percent rent reduction which means
the council house we've typically paid
eighty pound a week rent over the last
four years and reductions came into
force and now this 2.7 percent increased
rent that 8/10 rent will now be 78
pounds 92 so all tenants will therefore
still be paying less rent for the same
property in April 20 than they were in
April 15 for maintaining GAO's race at
the same levels of 1920 but we are
proposing to increase sheltered housing
services charges by 2 pound a week
I do understand members concerns has
raised a cabinet about this increase
that's a follow up is a fine our state
for more analysis to be done
that's being done it shows the 2 pound
increase goes less than half way
eliminate the deficit now in our deal
will there would be no deficit and no
cross-subsidy accordingly two pound a
week there's a minimum amount of the
increase that we can recommend this year
although I'm anticipating more work
we're doing this area in 2021 see what
cost savings may be achievable
also following on phone mute for utility
cost increases we're proposing to
increase sheltered housing utility
charges about 5% or 62 pence a week the
HRA budget includes a marked increase in
our new build and acquisition program
the capital costs are shown in Appendix
A and in the next four years forty four
point two million will be spent on new
housing work with I seen you this will
equates 185 affordable homes and 85
shared ownership homes we've major sites
being developed in need a market in
stone market middle school sites this is
an ambitious program but I would want
members to understand this is just this
is not the end of our ambitions for
house building merely the start
borrowing levels are shown in the
graphic in paragraph six which shows
after peak borrowing on 22 24 22 23 they
fall away quite steadily and of course
this sports our current page currently
sh1t show our budget which has a 30-year
business plan
produce the rolling basis to ensure its
sustainability housing is especially
stay with the council there so I'm
pleased to see that Gavin Fisk our ad
for housing my captain our housing
cabinet colleague council Flatman and
our finance team are here to assist me
in any questions arising on the report
I'd like to move the recommendations set
out in paragraph three that's my
colleague counsel clapping issues
it's a second thank you very happy to
second to recommendations okay Q so
we'll move into questions and questions
does anyone have any questions for
councillor whitehead
Samantha thank you I just like to ask
about the sheltered housing service
charge I don't believe this is the first
year that it has been increased by a
similar map my memories and I haven't
checked the data but I'm pretty sure we
have increased it you know the last
couple of years certainly last year as
well and I know that we have changed our
sheltered scheme and I just like to know
what people actually get for their
sheltered housing service that they're
paying more per week for my said looking
back over the last few years I've seen a
times when it's been frozen I've seen
the time when I think it went up by four
pound a week and I say I think to fully
eliminate that deficit we'd have to
increase the charges by four pound 18
which we're not proposing but sticking
is at two pound but in terms of the
details behind the sheltered housing
provisions are back to ask Gavin to
speak on that please thank you Thank You
chair I'm just in relation to service
charges there they're an accumulation of
a whole variety of utilities charges for
the the shared housing service such as
the scheme manager grounds maintenance
whole range of of services that are
provided we are intending to conduct a
review of the show at housing servers
this year and that will include those
child charges that residents have to pay
can't sleep don't you have a question
and thank you very much chair up to if I
may following on from the previous
question can I ask what we are doing to
keep utility bills low for um those in
sheltered housing services because it
seems that if that two pounds a week is
in reality four pounds 88 effectively
do we doomed to get that amount down and
secondly just with regards to the
investment within our own social housing
on paragraph 6.3 they refer to the debt
cap of for housings but the debt has
been removed and we are so therefore
we're currently able to borrow more but
that currently we're not looking to do
that on a long-term basis and by
long-term I mean you know 50 years
long-term so I just like to ask are
there any plans to investigate boring
over a longer period of time in order to
actually boost up our social housing
program thank you - I want to see your
first question so a second question
first one main I actually have written
notes here has to say that I wouldn't
members to feel that this first initial
investment program is the end of our
ambitious program for housing because
you see the it just all the way quite
drastically but wait so step by step
what we're doing so then we'll bring it
back another budget next year HRA
another rolling 30 year business plan
and the year after that I'm quite so
confident that house building will be
going on as a single future in terms
would be a question a feely question the
first question of perhaps there was a
little bit of a missing Sun between
utility bills and shelters service
charges but again if we could just
answer that thank you um with respect to
utility charges they're managed by
virtus we've based the costs on actual
statements that we've received in
relation to utilities obviously we have
a number of shell schemes across the
districts some of those have the benefit
of solar PV and what we do is we look at
the total totality of the utility costs
and then proportionally out of
across Chatwood housing to support
reducing the that level to the lowest
level for everyone concerned
and we are also in the process and
there's work going on currently to
install new central heating systems
through the use of ground saw ground
source heat pumps within some mid suffix
schemes at the moment to reduce the
overall costs and improve the
efficiencies Jakarta yeah I'm always
concerned being seen on camera standing
up this DWP to find out actually can't
stand but anyway I did once a regarding
V further charges on V show it had a
housing is that possibly a fee for the
advantages of taking their Maybelline
scooters away or is that a completely
different issue just wonderful
sorry into in terms of mobility school
storage we are obviously got an active
program of reducing the number of
mobility scooters that are stored in
flats or or in communal areas because of
the fire risk problem that they pose so
therefore we are investing in our stock
and investing in scooter storage where
suitable within our schemes both
counselor field you have a question yes
just about the level of rents the last
time my recollection we put up rents
were CPI plus 1% we were told don't
worry about it most people fifty percent
of their clients get that from Housing
Benefit and my interpretation was the
government saw us do that told us put
rents down for four years have you got
any assurances that that is not exactly
what's going to happen again if we will
go right to the limits of our allowance
no I mean I'm gonna second guess what
the government's position is
particularly with a new chancellor just
arriving um but I still think it's good
news five years down the line from April
15 our tenants are paying less than they
were five years ago
and we can only build our steadier plans
based on what we know at the moment we
will find out into course if things
change
counselor well thank you Jim um
sheltered housing service charges is it
not the case that as more and more of
our sheltered units become D sheltered
we've got as we've got a standard sort
of whipped up we're paying for the
management of the sheltered units as we
have fewer and fewer sheltered units the
cost per sheltered unit goes up is that
the reason why you're now seeking to
increase the service charges
no it's not the other residents in those
sheltered accommodations are actually
paying higher for their rental and
that's why it's under review so in a lot
of our housing where they're sheltered
places
we're not they're not have been taken up
so an ordinary people are renting those
places so they have to pay higher
because there is a sheltered
accommodation that's why it's under
reverb cancer after death question a
slight issue of the word ordinary people
with as opposed to people and share with
housing life do you pause
and surrounded you have another question
I just wanted a bit more clarification
Casa flatness said in the D sheltered
units within a area of sheltered and D
sheltered the people in the D sheltered
are paying or are they paying more for
their rent or are they paying more for
their service charges or are they paying
more for both gap in would you like to
answer that one so obviously both
councils mid Suffolk a few years ago
made the decision to following
Schaffhausen review to D designate some
of his units or some of its schemes
which was based particularly on on
demand where those units have been D
designated it's a case that someone
might move in and not require the
services of the the show at housing
officer so therefore they don't pay for
that service but obviously as demand for
that service falls then so does the cost
of that service so it is proportionate
in that respect just looking at some of
the things that make up those service
charges
it will include repair work to communal
areas it will include window cleaning it
will include things like Legionella
testing which we've invested in ensuring
that our schemes are safe as well as
some of the fire risk assessment works
that have been completed this year as a
result of of Grenfell and and the
hackett review in terms of the
additional investment that we've put
into ensuring that those sites are safe
for our residents so we'll move straight
to the debate
you would like to speak why should we go
straight to the vote okay penny okay and
yes I mean it easy issue
sheltered housing and the charges where
they have now been Dashell turd they
obviously don't have any access to the
alarm system consequently not are they
now going to be increasing their rents
they are now being four stretchy bari or
join a privately run alarm system for
example maybe by flagship or some other
organization at their own expense and
always we get the argument I have and I
find it very this not very pleasant
actually the argument that while the
majority of these people are actually on
some sort of Housing Benefit listen
those come out of the public purse
whichever way you look at it and I don't
consider that to be a correct argument
for doing so so I can't support this yet
again and Thank You counselor uber thank
you very much sir and I too got
particular issue with the shelter to
housing service charges and I think we
should be doing a lot more to try to
reduce that and to have I've asked
previously if that could be spread over
a longer period of time in terms of any
increases and to give you know the
council it seems where we're struggling
to find how to actually get that lower
and the limit eliminate some of that and
so maybe if it was spread over long
period of time we could have that time
to look at that and in investigators
that further I'm also concerned about
right to buy I'm very pleased actually
that righted by sales are much lower
than projected than we thought they
would be and but I do worry about how
that affects the overall business plan
of the HRA account and you know while
personally I don't support right to buy
as it is I think
social housing should be built for
social housing and remain that way in
perpetuity but I would like to see us
doing a lot more work on how that works
across the business plan and thirdly
actually as I mentioned in my questions
see greater investment
I appreciate we have started finally to
build our own housing stock again but I
would like to see a program over a much
longer time frame we we should be
looking at kind of a mortgage as it were
over 50 years plus here and in terms of
actually being able to deliver for our
residents and I don't really feel that
this current plan does that Thank You
chair Chancellor Mansell thank you III
am I tend to agree with much of in fact
nearly all of what my colleague calorie
burn has just said I I feel
uncomfortable about the the increase in
the payments needed for the the
sheltered housing units because I think
they may be the people who are least
able to afford the increase and I to
think that capital program is is is
unambitious
it's not ambitious enough work for the
last few years I mean in fact ever since
I've been on the council any knowledge
of what goes on in housing for which I
knew nothing before I started we've gone
on and on about the debt cap and the
fact that we weren't allowed to borrow
money and now this debt cap you know
it's applauded that it's now been
removed and yet I don't think we're
taking full advantage of the fact that
it's been removed and I think you know I
agree with counsel Kneebone we should be
looking at a more long term projects of
borrowing money to invest in in our
capital program of capital properties
cancer risk of thank you I just like to
give you an illustration of probably an
unintended consequence of some of the
savings made on the HRA income I note
that we've removed the decorating
vouchers for new tenants saving 3,000
pounds and also the removal of
decorating grants for tenants
have had their homes rewired I wonder if
you're aware I'm a charity trustee
within a charity in stone market and
this is something I raised at scrutiny
when this came forward and by removing
those vouchers the unintended
consequence is that some of those
tenants have now come to the trust the
charity for assistance with the cost of
painting their property and we are
already facing applications upon tenants
of this Authority for help towards the
painting costs we only help those who
are particularly vulnerable in stone
market and I wondered sometimes whether
we give enough thought to the unintended
consequences of an action that we take
here on this authority and I would just
make a plea the new few years when we
look at savings that can be made by the
HRA account that we look very carefully
at some of those things in future before
we actually implement them because it
has a real cost to most vulnerable
people in our community
that's the Wellum thank you Jeff yeah I
want to agree with some fellow
councillors that we really do need a
much more we need to be much more
ambitious in respect of building our own
council houses but but also I want to
speak to the service charges 30,000
pounds is very little compared with the
big jam-jar we've got over 9 million
pounds in but 2 pounds a week makes a
heck of a lot of difference to the
quality of life of some of our most
vulnerable people who are having to pay
that increase I'm sorry counselor lesson
thank you Jeff I was wondering whether
the proposes a little the chair might
agree to such a taking point three point
five and three point six as a separate
vote to give us the opportunity of
actually voting for something
yes I just did suddenly have a brain
wave it up but he wondered should I have
a Dakotan interest being what a viene
councilors live here to VHD living in a
council house moment by mid Suffolk very
bits of the council and I wish I had
known about the fun for the payment
would have been quite useful for me last
year
chairman if I could just clarify that's
covered by your dispensation counselor
class I'm gonna sort out about splitting
their the points up whatever you want to
just come back instead of Randolph
but in my introduction I just said that
I said well accordingly to pound per
week is a minimum amount of increase
that we can recommend this year so
whether it's taken separately or not you
know I would hope that all these all
these clauses are are agreed we could
take take more time and have two votes
Council yep so we're going to take the
recommendations 3.5 and 3.6 first
anyway we need to it we need to move
along as time is marching so we're going
to UM put those the boat now it's
recorded one so Jan is going to cool
everyone else just so this is just three
point five and three point six yeah
we're taking these two separately and
then we'll turn it the rest all together
so okay counselor so we're going to be
taken three point five and three point
six so if you can count ask if your four
against or abstain taken separately so
you are voting on that sheltered housing
service charges be increased by two
pound per week reduce the subsidy by
thirty pay and that sheltered housing
utility charges be increased by five
percent on average as terroristic 62
increased per week so those are the two
we're going to take know so if you can
say for against your stain cancel
Morrison counselor brewster counselor
burn cancer Carter you use Casa Celtic
Aston cancer ooh burn counselor Epping
non-cancer me
you can't change it I'm sorry counselor
Castlefield counts the Flatman four
counts of fleming counts of geek cancer
gold four counts of Guthrie counts for
heading him four counts of Hicks counts
of Humphries counts a Mansell yes
counselor Madison cancer melon council
mayor council Morni Oh can't similar or
council Norris counts the Otton counts
up are small counts the Pratt Council
Richardson counts the scarf cancer
stringer councillor Turner council war
boys council Wellum counts a white head
for okay so right comedy vote goes with
the four and that was a big waste of
time anybody saw a move on to the other
recommendations I will see I'm tired
it's staying late right so we're going
to go with the other recommendations on
block and I'm chance gonna fall out
again okay Castro Morrison counts let
Brewster count to burn counts of Carter
counts of Caston count Zoe burn
counselor Epping young counts of field
it's a Flatman counts of fleming counts
of geek counts of gold counts of car
three councils having them for coastal
Hicks Kelso Humphries can surmount song
cancer Matteson can't so melon
council mayor cancer Morni councillor
Muller council Norris cancer ah turn
hands to pass small cancer Pratt cancer
Richardson cancer scarf counts a
stringer cancer turner council war boys
cancer Wellum that's a white head so
that is Carey
moving on to Johnny's got something to
sing yeah sure if you don't mind I'll
I'll take this point and while Jan is
adding up the numbers on on the votes
and I just want to bring to your
attention chair into the chambers
attention council procedural 9 which is
the guillotine rule which means that
this meeting has to be called to a halt
at half past eight at that point any
business which is currently in progress
will need to proceed immediately to a
vote and then the council can choose if
it wishes to hold another vote to extend
the meeting or to adjourn the business
to an alternative date I would suggest
that the council does need to deal with
the gateway 14 item this evening however
chair you could choose to defer the
other items Thank You justice this is
the answer to Penny's question about the
number at the booth and chair so the
vote chair the voting on the last item
was twenty three and four nine against
and one abstention
so we're just a bit for now we're just
going to move to item 16 the resolution
to exclude the public because we want to
get the Gateway 14 being done first okay
so I'm sorry
Chau I'm sorry to interrupt um we just
need to be careful here if you move to
the gateway 14 item now and you go into
half-past eight you will have to cease
the delays immediately at half-past
eight so I would encourage actually a
member of the council to put a motion to
extend the meeting first have that a
second and voted upon and then we can
continue with the business in that
manner okay cancel it due to be family
or business tonight is urgent I propose
that we extend the meeting as long as
necessary second Thank You councillor
Kostich I'm happy to second chair so we
need a vote those in favor we're still
going to move to item 16 because we have
a couple of directors here we don't want
to keep them here all night what we
discussed up so if that's okay with
everyone pretty much can I get some nods
any notes at all thanks Matthew
so we're going to move to item 16 the
resolution to exclude the public 7 under
section 106 for the Local Government Act
1972 the public being excluded from the
meeting detected for item 17 and 18 on
the grounds that they involved the
likely disclosure of exempt information
as defined in part 1 of schedule 12a of
the Act in the paragraph registered
against each item could I have a
proposer thank you can I have a seconder
I'm happy to second chair thank you
so those in favor of excluding the
public its Carrie
thanks very much so moving on to I
you
[Applause]
all right so we're back to item 12 so
let's move along quickly people join
capital investment treasury management
strategies I'd like to invite John to
quickly introduce this paper and to move
the recommendations in the pool report
thank you madam chairman
yeah this third report I mean Tuesday is
the joint capital investment in the
treasury management strategy which
starts on page 11 23 the paper was
presented to cabinet early in the month
as already been submitted to full
scrutiny by joint audit and standards
committee it's a joint paper as the
tragedy's cover both babel and miss
suffolk and indeed all the many tables
within the report show the details of
both favored and myths of work the
report is produced annually and there's
been no significant changes in format
this year of course all the data
contained within the report has been
updated to reflect the latest capital
expenditure investment and borrowing the
latest treasury management investment
and borrowing positions of the
councillor the information is required
to be set out in the sit for treasury
management code of practice and
prudential code both which were
published in 2017 along with the MHC
algeria north on what the stands for now
investment guidance which was published
in 2018 um i've got a detail item a4
what's behind all the various appendices
but i think anybody wants to read those
that came in myself but if there are any
questions on individual reports
obviously we can answer those
a great deal of work has gone into
preparation of these documents a
particular like to acknowledge sue
Palmer for her dedication and diligence
in this area so propose the list
recommendation set out in section 3 on
pages 123 124 I said earliest been or
utilized by John Aldens standards and
that particular line to draw the
attention of members to recommendation
of three point eight which is new for
this year
and he arose from the joint board in the
standards committee scrutiny and was
accepted by cabinet thank you thanks I'm
can I have a seconder
thank you
happy to second that chair thank you
remove questions you have any questions
for um that's the whitehead no let's
quickly move into the debate you've got
a question debate okay Rachel hit it off
thank you very much chair I just with
regards to Treasury investment
strategies particularly the joint
investment strategy that's in Appendix B
as members in this room would know that
I'm have long since been against Cisco
as a vehicle for raising funds to mid
Suffolk and indeed many of our residents
are and in fact that's one of the areas
that and it doesn't matter what
political persuasion people are across
the board you know
people come to to us saying that they
really disagree with investing outside
of the district in shopping centers in
gyms in well we've got a BMW showroom
somewhere and so on so I'm still very
concerned that we are placing reliance
on that time what I'm happier to see
projects that just gateway 14 go forward
because that's within our I feel that's
much more than our remit and something
that we can really look to promote
ourselves and be proud of in our own
district but not for police outside and
like I say this is the 101 area where we
just get an awful lot of correspondence
from residents questions and parish
council meetings and so on that are
really unhappy with how this councillors
progress with Cisco and as such I can't
support that investment strategy Thank
You chair
Bruno's would like to speak get cancer
stirring up I just want to make very
small point about tsypko in its
investments I won't be supporting this
particular paper and it's get the
viewpoint if we were going to
increased council tax by half the amount
of the risk we're putting on the
individuals of midsummer district
council we'd have to have a referendum
but we can stack up that financial risk
as part of the tsypko on the individual
citizens of mid Suffolk and we don't
have to have that referendum and I
frankly think that's wrong I have
serious reservations about Safeco as the
coach even alluded to I still think we
could make more money is returned by
delivering on more of our corporate
strategy values and more of our
corporate objectives and I also think we
do it with significantly less risk
especially when I don't think there's
been a year when the income from Cisco
has exceeded the amount we've under
spent on our budget so I think it's the
wrong risk to deliver the answer to the
wrong question okay let's go to vote
people so the recommendations are right
here in your papers all those in favor
all those against any abstentions
okay that's um Harry
item number 13 a half year report on
traffic management I'd like to invite
councilor Miller to introduce the report
and to move the recommendations in the
report approved these recommendations at
our meeting on the 27th of January I
have a paper here which I could read out
but in the interest of time I would just
recommend that the recommendations as in
on page 183 3.1 and 3.2 they often
noting and I would ask for a second to
place cursor Caston very happy to second
that chair thank you any questions
cancer medicine yes sorry just just just
the one I just wanted to draw members
and cabinet members particular attention
to to section 11 on page 186 and I
welcome the statement that all council
activities will be will need to be
reviewed as part of the work that the
climate change task group I wondered
what additional resources are going to
be provided to help them do that because
that is a very big job actually this
report so we're gonna vote all those in
favor it's for noting yeah that's
carried number of item number 14
proposed changes to council meeting
dates I'd like to invite councillor
Molly to introduce the paper MC the 1941
and to move the recommendation in the
report Thank You chair and the these
dates are being proposed we've removed
two dates normally we do it on the fly
but all of our council business can be
accommodated within these dates and
there is no necessity to have the other
two in there thank you I would like to
ask for a second a second thank you very
much
um any questions Carol Ebert thank you
very much the chair I was gonna ask um
cuz in this report there wasn't a reason
given for why those there was gonna be
less meetings but councillor Morley has
has now didn't want to thank you for
that but I just worry that by reducing
the amount of council meetings we're
effectively reducing the Democratic
deficit and this there's a coming a more
of a democratic deficit in this district
and particularly that there aren't any
opportunities to meet outside of this
building and actually take the council
out to the residents and and perhaps
meeting their in you know the black born
or the you know one of the great places
we've got stone market and just hold
council meetings there rather than be
beholden to timings and things of when
this chamber is available or not would
appreciate it if that could be looked
into
Thank You chair good morning yes I think
um my personal opinion is that our
Democratic requirements are best served
by having the meeting in this chamber
where it is live streamed to every one
of our residents and relying on some of
our residents being
were to get to obscure out-of-the-way
places in our around our own villages
will cause them greater inconvenience
they've been able to watch it from the
safety and comfort of their own homes
they better we are forgetting the
elderly and be people who do not have
access to Internet who may not wish to
have a view of that and who may want to
participate and take part in a local
community and also going out to going
out to a meeting may be beneficial
especially with somebody's lonely just a
geek Thank You Chad I should point out
that they seem to be obscuring
out-of-the-way places when we want to
meet in them but when people want to
build 300 houses in there all of a
sudden very well connected on a
transport protocol easy to get to I
really can't follow that super quorum
yeah I don't take exception to calling
stone marketplace they obscure it every
way they are us of us than we are of
them and I really have problems with
this we've had constrictions on them at
a time we can ask questions at the
administration it is our duty as an
alternative administration to try and
hold that administration to account we
if this is agreed we'll have an hour and
a half a year to do that I frankly don't
think that's long enough
Mansell I'm sorry I thought we were
silly questions so I am I might have
missed my chance if willing to pay now
we debate while we questions am I
allowed to mention anything about debate
or a my own you add question right we're
in debate right so well I'm sorry but I
cannot support this this paper as has
already been said there was no reason
given in the paper to start with I agree
entirely with my neighbor here counts a
stringer that removing the the one or
the few opportunities that we have to
have a debate I think is dead
semental to our communities and I'm
sorry I think it's incredibly Indus dis
ingenious to say that sorting out dates
less than six months in advance is that
council dates are placed well in advance
into a member and office of Diaries six
months is not well in advance in my book
so I'm sorry I cannot support this it
goes against my my beliefs about
democracy and they've related to debate
and I will not be supporting this motion
okay let's go to debate because the car
park shuts in 20 minutes all those in
favor all those against any abstentions
no that is am past so I'm last one item
15 council appointments I would like to
move the changes listed in the table
papers are there any faith further
changes can I have a seconder please
Tesla eager so all those in favor
sorry sorry sorry
thank you then with the stifle debate
any questions no brilliant all those in
favor excellent that is past that is
over but meet again on Thursday the 23rd
of April at 6 5:30 thanks very much good
night